Так, доброго дня. Чути, видно мене?
Вибачте, трошки затрималась.
Доброго дня, доброго дня.
Так, доєднуємося.
Як Ви себе почуваєте сьогодні?
Можна голосом?
Як Ви?
Після транзактного аналізу ми всіх почуваємо себе.
Трошечки так.
трошечки так як це так з більшою глубиною про себе увлекательна вещь то це класно так
Так, так. Що нам вже горювати? Так, тільки радіти.
Добре. Горювати нам ніколи, нам дійсно треба тільки радіти.
Ось, яке горювання може бути.
Сьогодні вже такий закріплюючий, фінальний, інформаційний такий модуль, тому ми будемо потрошку-потрошку закріплювати всі знання, які ми отримали за всі ці 10 місяців.
Вчора сиділа, знаєте, рефлексувала і думаю, так, 10 місяців, нічого собі, 10 місяців вже пройшло. Як цей час бистро минув?
Швидко дуже.
Так, доєднуємося потрошки.
Бачу вас.
Так, 14.
Вмикаєте камери.
Так.
Лера, здраствуйте.
Так, так, так.
Как вам транзактний аналіз?
Отошли немножко?
Слышу.
да мне прям понравилось все супер насколько могу сегодня включена
коучинг тоже по максимуму буду включена надеюсь малышка отвлекать не будет
здравствуйте здравствуйте
Так, здравствуйте, Олена, Олена Сідик, Юля, бачу, Тетянка Карась, бачу, Уляна Дворцева, бачу, бачу, все, бачу вас.
Так, ви сьогодні з самого ранку, так, навчаєтесь? З самого ранку.
Ну, як завжди, як завжди.
Але все, скоро випускной.
Як завжди прийшли до вас вже стовплень.
Так, яка у вас тема була сьогодні в транзакційному аналізі?
Адаптації дитячі.
Дитячі адаптації.
Працювали, зачіпали травми, ні?
Ну, більше було про те, як ми діємо по життю, і такі там цікаві, цікаві моменти.
Виявляєте, я бунтар.
Ось так, бунтарів, в нас тут багато бунтарів.
Хто там ще є, окрім бунтарів?
Оказується, які бунтарі просто емпатти і манипулятори.
Вау!
Дуже так?
Інтересно.
Много бунтарей у нас в групі?
У нас основно трудоголики були.
Трудоголики.
Окей.
Оля Богдановська, віжу, да, присоединяйтесь к нам.
Анечка, Кароль, віжу, Кароль чи король, чи корол, не знаю як правильно.
Кароль, Кароль, да.
У нас багато емпатів, манипуляторів і трудоволіка, як вияснилось.
Це було інтересне ісследовання, правда?
Ну, емпатов, наверно, більше, тому що група така, да, коучей, психологів, понятно, що здесь буде багато емпатов.
Ну, да, ну, да. Помагаючій професії, да, багато емпатов. Важливо ще свою емпатію тримати, контролювати, витримувати свою емпатію, щоб не разрушатися, да?
Тому що це може привести...
Наразі емпатія потрібна в пользу манипуляцій.
Не завжди бути хорошою дівчиною.
Закритих манипуляторів теж багато.
Ана, як сьогодні ви?
У мені навіть відкритих.
Спасибо большое, Лера, спасибо.
Сьогодні сьогодні сьогодні у нас був шоппинг з сином.
Нужно було теж уделити внимання.
Ми літіли зберіли на максимум, як могли.
Старалися не приватити, на камеру не попадатися, але прилетіли, успіли.
Перша половина дні була така достаточна насыщена.
Тобто ми вже випускники.
Випускники вже. Старший син у мене випускник.
Здесь, в Великобританні, і вже потихонечку-потихонечку готовимся к випускному.
Правда, на випускной он йти не хочет.
Помните себе на випускному?
Девочки, хотели йти на випускной?
А вот он не хочет.
Говорит, що мне там делать на випускному?
Не хочу туда йти.
Ну, і таке.
День сегодня спокійний.
Але як в Великобританні, як настроення у жінки погода непонятна.
Все чотири сезона в один день, с утра солнішко, і град у нас був, і все у нас був, і дождик, і солнце, і зараз пасмурно, непонятно, що.
Така у нас інтересна переменчива погода.
Настроення, як настроення у дівшки, у жінки.
Окей, що ж, віжу, все вже уселись, все прекрасно, поїхали в сьогоднішній день, і так, хлопчиків не бачу, де наші хлопці?
На прогулянці.
На прогулянці?
Трішки пізніше приїдаємося.
Знову біжите.
Ви пішли вигулювати свого бунтаря, Юрій, чи емпат?
В мене маніпулятор.
Та емпатія і бунтарство лише заради маніпуляції.
Без них ще інші немає цінчі.
Клас.
Пішов вдихнути свіжого повітря, щоб вам видихнути свіжок маніпуляцій, коли вже буде розігріта група для цього і буде якась тема, яку можна задати.
А поки впитую то, що ви даєте, то б мозг генерував.
Добре. Добре. Дякую. Тож до зустрічі.
Окей, так, сьогодні ми завершуємо вчорашню тему і у нас сьогодні друга частина, де ми будемо розбирати деформацію ролі, етичну владу і завершення професійних стосунків.
Але спочатку хочу вас спитати про завершення етичних стосунків, завершення професійних, точніше, стосунків.
Як це для вас відгукується, коли ви завершуєте з клієнтом сесії повністю, коли ви завершуєте, як це для вас?
Як ви завершуєте? Що для вас завершення відпускання клієнта?
Коли ви відпускаєте, от все, на рільси поставили і відпустили в добрий час.
Як це для вас?
Чи пропонуєте ви щось клієнтові, коли відпускаєте клієнта?
Давайте, Настя.
Якщо б у нас був такий був більшій, багатий опит, як ми відпускаємо клієнтів, було тисячі відпускань, як шарики, можна було б поділитися.
А так, у мене було 5 сесій запись, а прошла одна, і на одному ми все рішили. І вже в переписки, що все рішено, побежав в щастливий путь.
Единствено, напомнила, щоб не забував, що для нього важливо, то есть його слова проговорить все. Отпустила, перекрестила і счастливий путь. Перекрестила? Ну, я образно, ну, как бы, мыслями. Товік пош
ел жити свою счастливую життя.
Добре, вас. Тетяна Артемова, ви як відпускаєте клієнтів? У вас є досвід вже?
Так, для мене це про фінальну сесію, фінальну в контракті.
Зазвичай це про рефлексію і розуміння того, до чого ми прийшли.
На це йдеться ціла сесія, але це дуже кайфовий такий шлях,
Коли я зазвичай, клієнт не впізнає якісь фрази, які я нагадую з першої сесії, наче це взагалі була інша людина, і клієнтка може казати, я таке говорила серйозно, я взагалі так мислила, ну просто взаг
алі не впізнають, тому для мене дуже важливо максимально детально першу сесію фіксувати, щоб потім це повертати, бо це прям дуже прикольна історія, бачити оцей контраст трансформації, забрати оцю силу
,
що за короткий шлях можна зробити отакий стрибок далі.
Так, це клас.
Так, дійсно. Дякую. Дякую, Тетяна, що поділилася.
Так, це дійсно так, коли є фінальна сесія і ми даємо такий фідбек,
повертаємо клієнтові все, що було на початку.
І дійсно так буває, зазвичай, майже 100%, коли клієнт каже, що як це могло бути, як я вже, та ні, я такого не казав, не казала, та ні, це взагалі не я, та ви що, таке не існує такого, ні, ні, ні, нія
к, ніяк.
Ось, так, дійсно, ми багато рефлексуємо, дійсно, ми багато повертаємо для того, щоб клієнт розумів цінність, скільки всього було пройдено.
Так і є. Добре.
Окей.
Так, про що ми говорили? Давайте ми теж фіналимо сьогодні.
Фіналемо ми з вами проходили і говорили про межі коучингу, професійну філософію вчора говорили, внутрішню опору вчора ми говорили, емоційне навантаження і яка в нас була невидима емоційна праця.
Ось, сьогоднішній день побудований на таких темах, які розглядаються у базових коучинг-програмах, але вони активно досліджуються в британських школах супервізії, в програмах Advanced Professional
Training, в коучинг-психології.
Тут також в нас і психотерапія, супервізія психотерапії теж трошки зачепимо сьогодні.
І в екзистенційних підходах допомагаючих професій.
Ми будемо говорити сьогодні не про успішний успіх в коучингу,
а про те, що професія поступово робить також із коучем.
І як може, ми вчора говорили про нарцисизм, трошки чіпляли цю тему,
і як сьогодні продовжимо, як влада може впливати на спеціаліста,
Влада над людиною. В деяких таких моментах в сесіях це про владу над людиною.
І як це може впливати на спеціаліста? Юрій, слухайте уважно тут.
Чому зрілість проявляється у здатності не провласнювати собі клієнта?
І як залишатися живою людиною? Завжди про це буду говорити всередині довгострокової практики.
Це стосується теми сесій 10, 5, 10, 12 сесій, або коли людина продовжує з вами практику,
і як там залишатися живою людиною, а не функціонуючим коучем, про котрого ми говорили вчора.
Сьогодні будемо досліджувати деформацію професійного коуча, втрату живого контакту з собою.
Це будемо розбирати також ми на практиці.
маски професійні свої і ризик емоційної диссоціації, владу коуча, так я сказала, та етичні ризики допомагаючої професії.
Ідеалізацію коуча клієнтом та залежність від авторитету є таке, коли клієнт прям підсаджується і все, ти його авторитет, він не може сепаруватися.
Будемо також говорити про зрілость завершення стосунків з клієнтом, як завершувати, як це в досвіді можна інтегрувати, ось це завершення, як приглашать клієнта на бустерній сесії, чому це важливо, це
дуже важливо.
Професійну зрілість та здатність не отримувати клієнта поруч з собою, як я й сказала, і яким коучем людина хоче залишатися через роки практики.
В першому блоці поговоримо про професійну деформацію коуча. Наша ключова ідея сьогодні – це не погані коучі, не помилки спеціалістів.
Ми сьогодні будемо досліджувати поступовий процес,
у якому професійна роль починає проникати в особистість людини
настільки сильно, що вона може перестати відчувати,
де закінчується її професія і де починається сама людина.
Тому що у допомагаючих професіях наших з вами
існує феномен, який в супервізіях та психотерапевтичних школах
називають professional deformation, професійна деформація.
Про це я казала вище.
Ось, чому взяла британське дослідження?
Тому що продовжую тут навчатися, продовжую тут досліджувати також і супервізійну практику.
І ця тема активно досліджується в контексті роль фьюжн, терапіст дріфт,
emotional distancing, professional identifier fatigue.
Тобто дослідження своєї ролі, де наша функція, як наша функція впливає на нас самих,
як може бути емоційна, яка повинна бути емоційна також дистанція.
Ось, коли коуч у нас виходить із своєї ролі, із ролі коуча,
ось, на початку практики ми зазвичай що робимо?
Ми з вами слухаємо, ми з вами аналізуємо,
ми з вами помічаємо процеси, відстежуємо емоції,
ми йдемо по всім компетенціям, які ми вивчали,
і бачимо всі паттерни людини.
Але з часом виникає все ж таки ризик, професійне спостереження починає ставати способом життя.
І це про життя в стилі коуч.
І коуч починає що робити?
Ми починаємо аналізувати близьких.
Піднімайте руки, хто вже аналізує своє оточення як коуч?
Чи аналізуєте ви хтось своє оточення як коуч, вже з позиції коуч?
Є такі з вас?
Нема ще аналізу?
Добре. Буде. Якщо нема, буде. О, Настя, бачу. Якщо нема, значит...
Мікається, полжизні коучу. Всех і всіх смутно. Вопрос в тому, що наблюдать і видіти глазами коуча – це одне. А коучить – це зовсім другое.
Абсолютно.
Щоб не було, щоб не було вот этого коучить, желання, я просто сказала, що коучи – только за деньги. Вот, поэтому...
Наблюдати і слідують, аналізірується, аналізірується, коучи аналізірують, можуть аналізірують своє оточення, своїх близьких, буває, що не може бути просто в контакті, автоматично може перейти в проф
есійну позицію, це можна відслідковувати, якщо наразі це непомітно, це може бути далі.
Це ок, якщо все це є в балансі. Це все ок, це норма, якщо є в балансі, якщо ми себе не втрачаємо. Також є ризик переставати проживати момент без внутрішнього аналізу. І тоді наша професія, вона
поступово, трошки-потрошки починає змінювати таку живу присутність людини. Ми становимося просто, стаємо як спеціалісти віздій всюди.
Це іноді називають в супервізійних школах living product observation instead of our experience. Таке буває, і це теж ок, як я і сказала, все в балансі.
Про професійну маску, ось тут також така цікава тема, але коли ви зайдете цілковито так просто будете занурюватися з головою в практику, в аналіз людини, ви також там побачите, яку професійну маску
ви можете надягати.
Це є профдеформація, ми говорили з вами про профдеформацію на шостому або на сьомому модулі, трошечки говорили про профдеформацію, де коуч починає несвідомо підтримувати образ усвідомленого, емоційно
зрілого, правильного спеціаліста, стабільного спеціаліста.
Тому що що? Тому що в якомусь випадку можеш сказати, ну ти ж психолог, ну ти ж коуч, ну ти ж коуч, що ти, ти ж щас зліжся. Таке теж може бути, але все залежить від оточення.
Коли ми хочемо зняти якусь таку професійну маску, можемо стикатися з тим, що ти ж коуч. Тобто це не насмішка якась, а просто таке повернення до твоєї професії.
Ну ти ж коуч, ти що, з цією ситуацією зараз не розберешся, ти ж знаєш, як можна тут вирулити.
І тоді спеціаліст поступово може втрачати право і злитися, і втомлюватися, і сумніватися, помилятися.
Ось, десь там може один ходити, гуляти, сам себе бродіти, тому що бувають такі моменти,
коли ти сам наєдині зі своїми мислями, просто з'єднуєшся з цим світом, і тобі ніхто не потрібен, тому що ти не хочеш чути вже лишній раз щось про себе, що ти ж спеціаліст, ти не можеш помилятися, ти
маєш бути так і так.
Ось, стосовно, взяла тут також з дослідження Дональда Вініко, який описував поняття false self як хибний, фальшивий, хибний я, хибного я, яке формується тоді,
Коли людина занадто довго підтримує адаптивний образ життя і втрачає контакт зі справжнім проживанням себе, як йому з цим самому, як він сам з цим справляється зі всіма своїми справами, згодами, незг
одами, що там відбувається в житті у спеціаліста.
І в цьому випадку, я вам хочу сказати, шановні колеги, дуже класно підтримує супервізія групи, плакатільні кімнати, які вчора вспоміналість, все це дуже класно підтримує.
У професії коуча це може виглядати як постійна така усвідомленість, як я сказала, відсутність спонтанності, бо це все треба проаналізувати.
І така професійна, виробатується професійна правильна мова і може бути така внутрішня емоційна порожнеча, скрита за таким стабільним образом.
Що таке в нас дисоціація коуча?
Тобто, в Advanced Professional Training Programs окремо розглядається такий феномен of emotional dissociation in helping professional, допомагаючи професії.
Це не треба порівнювати з таким класичним вигоранням, про яке багато говорять, професійне вигорання, професійне вигорання.
Це більше про такий стан, коли спеціаліст, знову ж таки, функціонує постійно і емоційно він вже віддаляється, він такий неприсутній.
Чи була у когось з вас, можливо, така практика з спеціалістами?
Може, ви заходили в якусь практику, де ви відчували емоційну відсутність спеціаліста.
От немає його емоційно.
От як Василь вчора казав, я каже, був на 60% продуктивний, на 40% я там не відчуваю себе продуктивним.
Катерина Ентель вчора казала про те, що я емоційно не була присутня на сесії.
Тобто, людині це допомогло, але допомогло чому?
Тому що людині потрібно було на той момент виговоритися.
Просто виліть всю історію і все.
А може ще у вас, у когось, можете згадати, була ли така практика,
де ви пішли до спеціаліста, а він емоційно відсутній.
Нема там спеціаліста, просто на автоматі сидіти.
Ходили в терапію?
Я можу поділитись своїм досвідом, але досвідом, який вже зараз я розумію.
Я мав два роки терапії, психотерапевт – це схема терапії.
За межами сесії за два роки, напевно, нас було два повідомлення по моєму западу.
Щось більше нічого не було, а решта тільки по організації.
І коли після того я мав психотерапевтку жінку супертеплу,
От я свого терапевта називаю тепер емоційно холодним.
Не факт, що він в той момент таким був, аж настільки,
бо я б два роки, напевне, не витримав,
але тут мені навіть пішло про те, що він був протилежністю мого тата.
Але коли я пізнав то, наскільки терапевт може бути теплим, вболіваючим,
і пішло поїхало то для мене він прям ну холодна ну типу диссоційована людина бо от для прикладу
те що було в нього обірвати стосунок з клієнтом все в нього клієнт стирається повністю і таке
відчуття він не стирається по через те що бо інші клієнти є а повністю типу от так як антисоціалу
що ми сьогодні з транзакційного оце прямо в мене було таке врежнє хоча для мене в сумі ця
ця психотерапія була корисною так тобто десь як але я розумію що ну може дійсно просто протилежність
тата не збиралася добралася і тоді тоді пішло дебузай ну прямо тут воно прямо і мені аж десь
себе сумно що десь оцей або я так знецінив або це реально було тут я вже десь я маю записи аудіо
кілька но повертатися до цього якось руки не доходять ну я вдячний за той досвід який був це
точно був мій старт ось він був в грі але сам по собі факт емоційно напевно холодний от ось так
так відчувалося тоді тоді ще напевне ні а вже ось зараз після смак от я проходив цю терапію
до 22 року умовно і про це почав думати останні півроку рік коли коли закінчив терапію з іншою
теплою терапевткою тоді прям в мене такі пішов і зовсім дві різні ці не знаю і думку може мій розум
знецінює не не не не спростую і не підтверджу але зараз якщо мати порівняння то да що той
терапевт був емоційно відсутній емоційно холодний теоретично да по щаблинах все теорія відігравала
все дитина доросла яку емоцію відчуваєш може навіть він і говорив я співчуваю та ну напевне це те що
я прочув і прожив, було один чи два рази.
Але тут, значить,
і я щось десь по емоціях не брав,
раз я таку людину підтянув.
Ну, але, тому отакий і мій досвід.
Дякую, клас.
Дякую, дякую.
На той момент буває
різні моменти, коли ми заходимо
до своїх терапевців. Різні.
Ми заходимо в різних станах.
Ми заходимо в різних станах, да?
І ось той стан,
який в тебе був,
він на той момент, як ти сказав,
відігравав тобі.
Тобто робив свою роботу, а потім, коли був вже інший стан, ми вже знаходимо інших спеціалістів, де вже захотілося більш теплості, можливо, десь погладжування, можливо, десь соболізнування, співчув
ання і так далі.
Тому що якщо перекинути і проаналізувати цього спеціаліста теплого з емоційно дистанційованим спеціалістом, то можливо ефекту б не було тоді такого, який ти звідти взяв.
Ось, тобто бувають різні такі випадки. І це класно, на кожний наш період, тобто є дійсно емоційно дистанційована така людина, спеціаліст, але на кожний наш період ми знаходимо собі спеціаліста,
які відгукаються по нашим цінностям, відгукаються по нашим поглядам,
як ми дивимося, в який напрямок ми дивимося разом.
Добре, дякую. Настя, хотіла щось сказати?
Ну да, я теж сталкалася з емоціональною холодністю.
У мене було таке відчуття в сесії, що людина взагалі не розуміє.
Настя, Федя, Петя, хто перед ним? Ну коротше, ми взагалі все одно було.
Це настільки така дистанція держалась, що настільки він отрішений був, що як би сам себе відсесію відвіл і, виходить, як поработав.
Ну, реально, мені пришлося включитися, знаєш, як отработати цю історію, хоча я нескільки раз спрашивала, ну, типо, все в порядку, ну, то есть у мене був фідбек і вже непонятно, хто кем вообще занимав
ся.
А хто у кого спрашивав, все в порядку?
Ну, я даже иногда спрашиваю, я що, розказую, розказую, я поворачуюсь, смотрю, а чека нет, ну, нет.
Тут не обманеш, це чувство внутренне, ти видиш, чоловік отрішений, і ти кажу, і я йому, все в порядку? Алло, мама, папа дому? Ана так, да-да, я взяла внимание, продовжайте її. А я думаю, переспрошу
сейчас своє імя, думаю, вспомнят или нет. Ну, в общем, вот такое було відчування. Точно, я його іспытала, і думаю, блин, це може, така роботизованна історія була. Чесно, не знавала, а такий, може, ч
оловік і є сам по себе.
а може, що-то сьогодні случилось, але мені вже ця історія була неінтересна.
Долго ви були з таким спеціалістом?
Як вам взагалі?
45 минути.
І все.
Більше...
Ні, потім я сказала, що у мене зв'язь плоха, я перезвоню.
І все, і вийшло, мені надаєло танці з губнами робити.
Але в твоїй розповіді вийшло чуть не місяцями, ти так з ними була, знаєш,
ніби така історія травмуюча, довга, прямо я так це бачила.
Так 45 минути.
45 минут одна сесія, правда, зашла.
Ну і, опять же, і інструменты.
Был такий, що мені сам інструмент не нравиться.
В гештальті я просто не зашёл.
Я 10 цих занятий еле, честно говоря, отсидела.
Це треба було для академії і чому-то.
Мені вообще не зашёл вже.
Там не хватає глибини, вот, поэтому.
Окей.
Це в Герштальте. А в цьому, де був отрішений психотерапевт, як ви говорите?
Тоже був Герштальт, так.
Я для себя решила, що мені потрібно для Академії Герштальт пройти 10.
Ну, чому-то у мене так сложилось. На першому слайшала модуль, що мені треба туди, і у мене просто були знакомі.
Тому і пошла.
Верто, я знала, що по-другому.
Окей. Да, так і буває.
Дійсно, буває, зараз продовжую, тут дійсно цікава така тема, і важливо це запам'ятати, розуміти, для себе розуміти.
Я розумію, що на даному етапі це може десь для когось ранувати, може десь ще не кожен може усвідомлювати, як це, переставати емоційно бути присутнім.
Але це буває, так, така емоційна асоціація коуча буває.
Ось, коли це буває, коли людина, тобто спеціаліст, звикає до втрат, до болю, до криз.
А, там, знаєте, ще одна кровь, ну, ладно, ще один труп, ну, ладно, вже так, розумієте, ще один безголовий, ну, добре, ще одного режем, хірург, ну, отлично, все, це просто тіло.
Людина звикає, тобто спеціаліст звикає до сильних емоцій, і нервова система в нього вже починає трошки захищатися, і емоційне дистанціювання проходить в цих моментах, проходить також внутрішнє онімін
ня, і вже контакт такий автоматичний, він просто вже автоматичний.
І звісно, що коуч може звучати дуже професійно, дуже професійно, все буде класно, дуже професійно, але користі там треба звірку постійно робити і як клієнту, і також і коучу, звірку зробити і питати,
а що мені зараз важливо в цій сесії з тобою, так?
як ви можете як клієнти питати звірку як як ви думаєте клієнта у вас як може спитати звірку
як як клієнт може звіритися з вами як зі спеціалістом
фразами ви мене розумієте взглядом притулитися поближу
а що ви думаєте а що тут краще зробити ну тобто питаю чи спорати вони будуть звірю
зверятися перекладати від туди не ставимо так чи може клієнт в цьому випадку маніпулювати
та і сам коуч може маніпулювати коуч може все коуч може провокувати і дійсно може
Іноді це корисно, коли ми вводимо клієнта в фрустрацію, іноді це дуже корисно, коли ми фруструємо клієнта, важливо розуміти, коли і як це зробити.
У нас була практика, по-моєму, восьмому модулі, де я даже запам'ятала Катю Інтель і ще ще хтось, був в кімнаті, і дуже така була фрустрована сесія.
Тест транзактного анализа
Нужно сначала дать
Понять, хто он? Бунтарь, манипулятор,
эмпат?
Да-да-да, щоб понять, с кем ти тягаєшся
Да, і
Желательно пройти тоже тест на Ненсі Маквильям
Вот
Давайте пройдем, що це за тест
Ми не проходили
Кидали його
Очень багато раз в чат
Настя, я вас ночую
Несколько раз кидали
Я його несколько раз проходила
у мене там по нулям все время, я периодически захожу, проходить.
Удивительно, що у вас по нулям. Продублируй, пожалуй, табличку, Настя.
Можна ще раз в чат. Да, тест Нэнси Маквилием це на психотипи. Разумити. То, я, то.
А если у Настя по нулям, то шо, на что? Нет, все стабильно.
Ким угодно, і шизофрінікому питання, ким угодно.
Ти хитрая маніпуляторша.
Так, там може бути, звісно, тести можна обманювати, але там 70 питань, я не думаю, що класно їх обманювати.
Желательно пройти їх чесно.
Да, там шість чи восемь типів личності, шість типичні, психопатічні, нарцисні, маниакальні, депресні, там багато типів личності для того, щоб розуміти, я рекомендую давати його клієнтам, щоб розуміти
, з ким ви працюєте.
Це такий лайфхак.
Я розказувала, що Ненсі Маквіліум – це людина, яка тісно причетна до книги ICD-11 и DSM-5.
Це наші МКБ, міжнародня класифікація захворювань МКЗ.
Вона є дуже значущим і аналітиком, і психотерапевтом, де зібрала все в цей тест, і цей тест зарегламований, запатентований, він також базується на цих книгах, щоб розуміти, який тип особистості ви є.
Добре, далі, поїхали. Так, коуч може втрачати живий зв'язок із професією і рідше може бути таким включним і справжнім. Чому ця тема важлива на сьогодні? Тому що зрілий коуч, зрілий ментор-коуч – це
зовсім не та людина, яка ніколи не втомлюється.
Ми можемо і втомлюватися, ми можемо бути нестабільними. Зрілість – це якраз про здатність помічати власні зміни, не розчинятися в ролі, бачити вплив професії на себе, повертатися до себе як до живої
людини, мати контакти з собою, з соціумом. Це дуже важливо.
На черзі у нас сьогодні практика. Хочу, щоб ви швиденько її для себе пройшли.
Ось, чи готові ви до практики?
Ви сьогодні практикували в транзакційному аналізі, скажіть, будь ласка?
Так.
Супер, супер.
І сьогодні з вами теж попрактикуємо.
Так, так, так, так. Практика в нас 30 хвилиночок з фідбеком у залі. Добре, бачу, слухач, слухач, бачу.
Що стосується практики? Коли клієнт говорить з позиції коуча, який поступово починає помічати в тому від постійної ролі,
неможливість вимкнути професію, неможливість вимкнути професійну маску і помічає втрату живого контакту з собою.
Робота у нас в парах, практика – це є як професійна саморефлексія.
Звісно, що другий учасник у нас не аналізує, не коучить на результат і не шукає рішення.
Коуча задача – допомогти людині глибше дослідити свій внутрішній професійний стан.
Тобто, як це розуміється?
Приклади питань собі заскріньте.
Десь приклади питань можуть повторюватись, це нормально.
Зробіть собі скрін.
Давайте зробимо цей ривок сьогодні.
Давайте його зробимо.
Ось.
Чому?
Значить, чи все ви розумієте з практики, що ми робимо?
Не відхиляємось від коучинга.
Запитання. Так, ставлю.
Ставлю запитання.
Заскрінили, так?
Іринко.
Ірина Купчик.
Так, дякую.
Добре, добре. В очікуваному результаті я чекаю від вас вплив професійної ролі на особистість, досліджування власної професійної маски, якщо це вдасться, буду дуже надіятися, що вдасться, усвідомлені
сть ризика емоційної диссоціації і, звісно, повернути увагу до власної живої присутності.
Ось такий очікуваний результат в мене від вас.
Я хочу прогулятися по залах і це почути, не випадаючи від самого коучингу.
Добре?
Добре.
Окей, 30 хвилиночок.
Зали в нас готові.
Так, Юлечка?
Да, в самому тобі я тут даю слухачі і відкрываю.
Дякую.
Заходьте.
Рок і яйто.
Дякую за перегляд!
Доброго дня!
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Боже, ви навіть не розумієте, скільки глибини і скільки рефлексій я зараз почула в залах.
Я дійсно дуже рада, що ті, хто доєднується до, все ж таки, такого формату спілкування, працюють з цим.
Звісно, ті, хто не мав змоги доєднатися, це такий пропуск, але, слухайте, це неімовірно.
Глибина, рефлексія, яку ви там розбираєте, ось це і є завдання, щоб ви порефлексували, де ви є, як ви є, куди ви хочете йти,
Де ви хочете зупинитися, що ви хочете почати, кому що треба, які цінності ви прислідуєте, наслідуєте.
В одному з залів я почула таку річ, що я коли на це дивлюся зараз, коли я почала навчання, розуміла, де я знаходжусь.
І зараз я дивлюся на це і розумію, що я хочу просто зупинитися.
Хтось каже, я хочу просто зупинитися, і це норма.
Ось для цього потрібні такі практики, ось для цього, щоб ви могли зупинитися, щоб ви могли зрозуміти, де ви знаходитесь зараз.
Що зараз в моменті, ось навчання вже закінчується, що зараз в моменті з вами кується, де ваша точка старту.
І точка старту, вона не про досягнення завжди, не про те, що треба досягати щось.
От зараз ми будемо досягати, зараз ми будемо щось колаборувати, щось будемо робити.
Для когось це так є добре, для когось ні, для когось це інший старт.
І це класно, це класно, я дуже-дуже вам вдячна.
Сьогодні, коли ми говоримо про тему завершення, як завершуємо професійні стосунки з клієнтами,
Ми говоримо також про такі речі. Дивіться, вчора також ми підіймали цю тему, що любая вещь, которая сказана клієнтом, она есть его правда, она есть его точкой старта.
І навіть якщо ви не донесли якусь там істину, якщо ви там щось не вважаєте, що щось не доробили, щось не додали, або клієнт там не стартанув туди, куди він хотів, спочатку на точки А свого запиту, а
потім там дійшов кудись і напрямок змінився, це теж все ок.
І зараз у вас це відбувається. Ось тут, в рефлексійних кімнатах, де ви проводили оцю практику рефлексійну, вона здебільш рефлексійна така. Де ви, куди ви йдете, що ви робите, заради чого ви робите це
, заради чого більшого ви це робите.
Ось це є масштаб. Ось це про ваш масштаб. Внутрішній і зовнішній. І як спеціаліста, і як людини, бо ви тут за 10 місяців ого-го пропрацювали свої і травми, і свої запити, і багато чого, чого ви там
боялися десь, і могли б не сказати.
Я з самого початку вам казала, пропрацьовуєте тут, все, що є тут в Вегасі, воно залишається в Вегасі, а якщо там є осередки, де ви можете поділитись, добре, це клас, це супер, що ви можете з кимось
поділитись і далі йти, але це неймовірна праця, неймовірна праця, це не просто знання, не просто знання, які ви тут здобули, це ваше посилення, в першу чергу ваше посилення, посилення вас самих, як
особистостей,
особистостей, вас самих як і коучів, і спеціалістів, і як особистостей в першу чергу.
І це класно. Я дуже рада, що ви так відкриваєтесь і йдете далі, і працюєте далі.
Працюєте над собою в першу чергу. Не просто для завдання, щоб виконати його, а працюєте над собою.
Класно. Вдячно. Вдячно. Супер. Просто супер. Неймовірно.
Дякую велике. Поїхали далі.
Сьогодні у нас така спокійна робота, без гучних емоцій таких.
Я сподіваюся, що ви дослідили свої професійні маски, які ви могли б надягати, або вже помітили, що надягали.
Де ви розуміли свою живу присутність, де ви розумієте вплив своєї професійної ролі на особистість. Чи є у когось з вас можливо якісь інсайди або можливо просто якийсь відгук, що відгукнулося, що в ре
флексії, що рефлексія вам дає.
Бо рефлексія, то в першу чергу, це ваша сила, як я і сказала.
Це про рефлексію.
Коли ви можете самі аналізувати, запитувати себе,
давати собі ці запитання.
Чи є щось, з чим ви могли б поділитися наразі?
Якщо ні, це теж ок.
Даліна.
Добрий день, Ланочка.
Добрий.
Со вчорашнього дня, то, що ми в комнатах тоже працювали, Маша і Катя, я не знала, як мне втулити наставничество і коучинг в мій бізнес, а вчора все стало на свої місто, і я тепер понимаю, я, оказыває
ться, наставничество даю безплатно во время обучення массажу.
Тепер я можу це просто відсоєдити і давати віддельним курсом за гроші.
А я туди вваливаю всю інформацію і делай раз, делай два і я на зв'язі з вами год.
Тобто тут я теряю гроші.
І вчора, да, дівчці, спащіба всім.
Спащіба, Вана, за платформу, яку дала нам для роботи.
І Юля, Катя. Тоже спащіба.
І сегодня ще, кстати, да, Анастасія дала теж, що ми двері изучали.
Тобто це відличні воронки, як я бачила, для моих клієнтів.
Почувайте, як я роблю массаж, слухте, що там у нас.
Тобто у мене просто собралися пазлы. Спасибо большое.
Ви слухаєте силу в себе, слухаєте, як ви можете це монетизувати.
Як це про роботу, про монетизувати?
Ви слухаєте, як ви можете це монетизувати?
Ви слухаєте, як можна це відсоєднити, продати, предложити.
Ви слухаєте це, і це благодаря також більшому кількісті розговорів.
Тому що ми постійно-постійно рефлексуємо і говоримо.
Постоянно на ці теми.
Задавая себе, пітаєсь постійно задавати себе точні вопросы,
які попадуть именно в точку.
І це ще раз, не факт.
Вчера где-то не догнала, а где-то тут догнала,
потім перегнала, потім опять где-то ви опоздали, може бути.
Ми все так робимо, це не касається тільки лично вас, Елена.
Це касається кожного із нас. Каждий знаходить точку силы, точку росту, точку опору в себе там, де в його време, в його важний час, в його нужне време, тільки тоді, коли йому це необхідно.
От дійдет, коли дійдет, так і з клієнтами, як до них доходить, дійдет через п'ять, отлично, хорошо, прекрасно, і через три, і через десять може бути, і через одну, хто закриває через одну сесію, да?
Дякую. Клас. Супер. Супер.
Сьогодні я почула також в одному залі про достатність.
Я думала, що щось ще не достатньо, а вже достатньо.
А вже виявилось достатньо, теж пазлики зібралися, вже є сила.
Вже відчувається ця сила, відчувається ця мощь внутрі, що вот я вже могу.
Я вже достаточний спеціаліст з великим кількістю практик, з великим.
Для себе, в першу чергу.
Могу йти далі.
Я це теж просила.
І це теж про вибір, про рішення.
Клас.
Супер.
Достукуватися до себе – це найважливіша частинка нашої праці з клієнтами,
де вони будуть відчувати від нас оцю емоційну стабільність.
Не холодність, а стабільність.
Де треба їй дати і тепло, де треба дати і зазвичай і з дистанцією,
так, буває, так, і треба і дистанцію дати.
Де треба дати пенділя подзад, хорошого такого, так, теж треба.
Фрустрація у нас це називається.
Фруструвати трошки клієнта, щоб він там розізлився щось,
Показав свої зубчики, де, на що, на що він як реагує.
Це теж треба.
Окей, клас, дякую.
Супер, поїхали далі.
У кожного свій шлях, і це прекрасно.
І ми відносимося до нього з повагою.
Ідемо до другого блоку, де поговоримо зараз про етичну зрілість і владу коуча.
Владу, бо ми маємо владу.
А знаєте, як ми маємо владу?
Ой, розкажу вам такий случай,
взагалі, просто неймовірний.
Значить, в мене є клієнтка,
вона дуже швидко росте.
Її 24 роки всього, а вона вже тут тренує,
вона вже є тут тренером.
Це стосовно ленгвіч,
язика, англійського язика.
І вона настільки швидка і потужна в своїх рішеннях,
що вже за 24 роки тут навчається паралельно
в двох вузах, сама собі оплачує.
значить, веде, вела приватні уроки англійської мови,
а зараз вона вже тренер, і зараз вона вже не просто тренер,
а вона вже проводить обзервацію, вона тренер для вчителів,
компанії, ребятки, 24 роки, перша в мірі в цьому статусі, в мірі.
І коли вже її почали публікувати на сайті, що є така дівчинка,
Це просто неймовірно.
І ми з нею в роботі.
Ми з нею в роботі не про травми, не про якісь діагнози.
Ні, ми з нею в роботі про підсилювання і про те, щоб вона могла витримувати всі ось ці етапи, через які вона проходить.
Розумієте?
І вона їх витримує.
Тобто, якщо наша психіка десь може просто отак схлопнутися в якомусь періоді, де ми там звикли реагувати, реагувати так, як реагуємо зазвичай,
то вона вже підготовлена і завдяки тому, що вона відчуває свою силу, людинка вже не просто тренує.
Там обзивація, це я не знаю, як грамотно пояснити з точки зору її роботи, але це звучить умовно так, що вона тренує і вона оцінює великих вчителів українка наша, великих вчителів англічан, розумієте?
Ну це просто, ну капець, 24 рочки. Просто, неймовірно. І вона чотко розуміє свою цінність, вона чотко розуміє свою силу, вона знає, куди йти.
Про що це? Про те, як ось це наставництво, ось цей супровід нас, як спеціалістів, дивіться, як підсилюють.
Вони підсилюють. Клас! Я very proud.
І повернемось до теми про владу коуча. Я чому це розказала зараз, цей приклад, про владу коуча. Коли ми відчуваємо владу і коли ми балансуємо і знаємо, де є кордони, щоб не привласнювати успіх клієн
та, прям привласнювати там, що це я зробила з неї таку людину.
Ні, це завдяки нашій роботі. І це, от, very different. Разне, тому що, коли ми кажемо, я з неї зробила таку людину,
бо зробив таку людину, що вона зараз і то, і то, і то, і то. Це про, якщо пам'ятаєте, вчорашній день,
про нарцисизм і про владу, про те, що ми присвоємо всі ці заслуги клієнта.
А ось про етичну зрілість та владу, ключова ідея в багатьох базових програмах коучинг
подається як безпечна надиректовна професія.
Слухайте уважно, прочитайте уважно.
Ці слайди за ці два дні, якщо ви помітили, їх багато.
Їх 40 або 50 слайдів, бо розписано прямо сильно-сильно, для того, щоб ви користувалися, щоб ви поверталися до цих тем, коли ви будете далі-далі-далі собі йти по своїй сходинці професійній, хто буде й
ти далі, хто не буде, окей, хто буде, це вам буде корисно.
Повертайтеся до цих слайдів, бо, як сказали в одній з кімнат, так, питання вже для таких людей, які дійсно вже загружені і практикою, і клієнтами, тут прям ось такий матеріал.
Я розумію, що для людей, хто не сильно практикує або ще не має великої практики і не має такого загрузу-перегрузу, це трошки, знаєте, як з іншого виміру, що а що тут такого, а що тут такого, може бу
ти і так.
У мене також була така реакція, коли я тільки-тільки починала свій професійний шлях. Це теж ок.
Дивіться, в Supervisual School і Coaching Psychology давно досліджується така тема, що коуч завжди має вплив, дійсно має вплив, навіть якщо він не дає порад, навіть якщо він не нав'язує ніяких рішень
, не займає ніяку авторитетну позицію.
Сам факт того, що клієнт у вас вже відкривається і шукає підтримки, це вже дає вплив, тому що клієнт бачить у коучі більш стабільну фігуру і це вже створює таку асиметрію впливу, розумієте? На безсоз
нательному уровні вже створює цей вплив, ви вже можете впливати.
Але ще про цю маніпуляцію, яку ви сьогодні також розбирали, і ці ризики, де можна її маніпулювати. Але я хочу сказати, не рекомендую заходити в цю тему стосовно маніпуляції.
Так, це можна, але використовувати це до передовремня.
Ну, повірте, до передовремня воно швидко проходить.
І не завжди дає гарні плоди.
Ось, як це перейсходить?
Ідеалізація коуча.
Коли коуча ідеалізують, ось, у довгостроковій роботі клієнт що може розробити?
Він починає ідеалізувати коуча, переписувати йому особливу мудрість.
там мій кож, там такий просто там все, там хвалю, Боже, Вася, цар і Бог,
або там Оленка, цар і Бог, прям, не знаю, от кланююся в ножки вам, да.
Залежить від його схвалення, коли ми супертеплі і коли клієнт приходить,
а у нас у всіх, не у всіх, не будемо обобщати, давайте так,
ну, большой процент такий, великий дуже відсоток, коли людина приходить,
бо ми розуміємо, що нас там мало кого там в дитинстві хвалили, да,
там нахвалювали і все тому подобне да було може бути було але не вистачало і хотілося цінності
визначності і все тому подобне і коли людинка клієнт знаходить такого коча який на кожній сесії
там да ти молодець ти да ти понімаєш ти уже все зділа там да ти да ти просто царі Бог ну просто
розумієте ось така вся ситуація то людина вже залежить від цього схвалювання то все підсадили
на гачок і там не буде автономії там не буде автономії він втрачає автономію залежить від вас
ось і клієнт починає згодом вірити вже що коуч знає краще що ментор коуч наставник він
може знати краще все він знає краще мені срочно нужно мені срочно потрібно і так далі так далі
ми ж не хотімо бути наркотиком правильно для своїх клієнтів і ось тут починається оця
етична відповідальність спеціаліста.
Етична відповідальність.
Ось, є прихована така влада,
це найнебезпечніша влада,
вона прихована, вона не відкрита.
І як коуч, може її, спеціаліст,
може її не до кінця помічати.
Наприклад, приклади я тут навела,
такі дуже банальні,
коли спеціаліст починає насолоджуватись ролью
того, хто бачить глибше,
Дуже абстрактно тут, дуже приклади абстрактні, коли клієнтське захоплення стає джерелом самоцінності, от все, клієнт захоплюється, це моя самоцінність, мені треба десь самоствердження.
Коли коуч не свідомо, підтримує залежність клієнта, і це не на свідомому рівні, або коли професія починає задовольнати потребу у значущості, значущість, самоцінність і так далі.
В британських тренінгах, супервізійних тренінгах, це вважається однією з найважливіших тем професійної зрілості. Ось ця тема найважливіша. Я там вчора також говорила про найважливішу і сьогодні кажу
про найважливішу. Ці всі теми найважливіші, бо вони знову і знову по колу, знаєте, як жвачку, їх круцять і круцять і круцять, тому що все це важливо.
Все. Тому що ця незріла влада, вона, як ми і сказали, руйнує автономість, створює залежність і зміщує фокус клієнта.
Етична зрілість коуча, в першу чергу, це здатність постійно досліджувати власний вплив, як це відбувається.
Це відбувається в саморефлексії, коли ви ведете щоденечок саморефлексії після сесії. Якщо маєте щось таке, що вас десь зачепило, або розумієте, який вплив ви дали, тобто почули від клієнта, поверт
айте себе, бажано повертати себе у свій професіональний стан.
Здатність не використовувати клієнта для підтвердження власної цінності. Треба дуже постаратися. Не будувати роль особливого спеціаліста, що тільки я і більш ніхто не зможе вирішити цю твою проблему,
як я це зроблю.
І не ставити центром життя клієнта, звісно, щоб ми не крутилися тільки навколо клієнта. Зрілий коуч, він створює простір, звісно, і не створює культ власної особистості, не отримує клієнта, звісно,
не робить себе незамінним.
Чи можете ви на такому прикладі, так, час, час, 16.34, опа, ми йдемо на перерву зараз, давайте так, трошечки здвінімо перерву, буквально на декілька хвилин.
Питання. Чи можете ви дати декілька таких прикладів, де просто, не знаю, гіпотетично, де, як, в яких випадках коуч має владу, вплив і клієнт прямо його центр?
Як думаєте? Подумайте.
ось дивіться ситуацію
простий такий приклад графік
скільки клієнтів можна взяти в день
Це в першу чергу покаже, який ви спеціаліст
І що клієнти не є вашим центром
Гроші не є вашим центром
Де можна втрачати свій ресурс?
Це в першу чергу
Де є спеціалісти, який ресурсний на три клієнти, на два клієнти, на одного клієнта
Є спеціалісти, які кажуть, що є ресурс на 10 клієнтів.
В мене там 7-10 клієнтів в день.
Про що це?
Скільки супервізій нам потрібно використовувати,
якщо ось так в нас 7-8 клієнтів в день?
Розумієте про масштаби?
Що тоді цей спеціаліст шукає в своїй роботі?
Значимість.
Подтвердження своєї ценності.
Подтвердження ценності, значимість своє.
Далі.
Що так багато тоді і грошей?
Звісно.
Наскільки може корисним бути такий спеціаліст?
Я не кажу зараз про те, що гроші нам не важливі, вони нам завжди важливі.
Всім важливі гроші. Всім.
Але ж свою значимість і свою цінність можна формувати так,
що в тебе два клієнти, ти заробляєш стільки, скільки ти б заробив з 10 клієнтів.
Ось про це. Ось я зараз кажу про це.
І, звісно, про те, що клієнти йдуть, йдуть, йдуть, йдуть,
І впливає коуч на них, бо спеціаліст або це може бути психолог, психотерапевт, неважливо, допомагаюча професія, коли люди йдуть і розуміють, що там є, там моє рішення, там моє рішення, все, мені ср
очно потрібно тільки туди, я без цього спеціаліста не можу жити.
Тобто, в першу чергу, відтворювати для себе екологічну середу, де ви розумієте етику, дотримуєтесь її і себе ніяк не теряється.
Ось я про це.
Добре, окей, ідемо з вами, розумію, що ви дуже такі, після, після утра транзактного аналізу, теж після обучення,
ідемо на 10 хвилиночок на перерву і повернемося в 49 минутик. Чекаю на вас.
Дякую за перегляд!
Василю, ти непреривно тут?
Так, я непреривно пахаю зараз, останні три тижні.
І зараз хочу від тебе втікнути, доробивши карусельку, втікнути в хамам.
я згаджую другий вечір підряд тобі з хамамом можна, я тобі скажу, я вчора після
коучинга побігла в сауну, це було просто насолодження, я так гарно попарилась,
просто вона в нас працює до 10 до 10 годинки і взагалі це було дійсно супер ово ось воно так ну без
того я б не вижу а я ж зараз через аїшку генерую карусельки і все решта і це і це прям дуже круто
воно саме створює за 10 хвилин я його редагую і т.д. і т.п. тому щирий рекомендаційон таку штуку
собі теж зробити кидай мені посилання я вивчу добре я більше скажу на наше може сама публікувати
це як може я ще не доріз і публікує і генерує і створює і вивчає із твоїх
але Юр я все-таки коригую що вона генерує розумієш тобто десь тому вона там як почала в першому
мені сторітелл видала теми табу, що там би мене заклювала половина моїх людей, тому я десь, ну типу я
тільки вчусь. Ну все, чекаю на тебе, чекаю на тебе в приват. У нас, кстати, класний якийсь, а ладно, не буду.
Ну, до речі, Юра тою самою штукою займається, то можна, і щоб Юра тобі розказав теж, якщо ти можеш його теж попросити,
бо Юра більш в тімі і т.д. Я можу послати тебе до людинки, в якої я це роблю, а Юра це прямо така сама
людинка як та людинка в якої я це роблю ну якось так ну клас супер спитаюся Дякую Добре Любі
повертаємося ідемо далі в практику у нас сьогодні три практики три такі рефлексивні практики
їдемо далі в нову практику і тут я хочу щоб ви трошки погралися от мені хочеться щоб ви
Щоб ви погралися в клієнта, зараз вам скажу, в клієнта, який захоплюється своїм коучем.
Так, вибачте, це в нас не та практика.
Не та, хвилиночку.
Хвилиночку, хвилиночку.
Прикольно, Лана, як ви так зробили?
Що?
Назад, там ви якось, коротше, роздвоїлися і були на презентації у мене.
Так, я знаю, я тут теж граюся.
Як це? Я так не вмію.
Навчу. Це в зумі розширення таке.
Так, зараз. А ну-ка.
як як це робить А клас Меджік Меджік а не що з Клода спитаю ну правда а от ви знаєте а я в Клода не
питала знаєте ось не завжди все у Клода треба питати завжди все треба питати ні не завжди так трошки
В мене відкрилися всі вікна презентації, тому що я їх переглядала.
Ось наша презентація.
Я хочу, щоб ви ідеалізували коуча.
Прямо, щоб ви ідеалізували.
Зараз я вам її відкрию.
Ось.
Бачите так?
Покажемо.
Юлька, у мене пишет ваша демонстрация экрана приостановлена. По какому случаю я не розумею?
Юлія, ви тут?
Так, ви попробуйте вимкнути демонстрацію і заново включати.
Та ось, вже пробувала.
Так, вимикаю.
Вимикаю і заново поділитися.
І заново включаю.
Ні, демонстрація приостановлена, каже.
Ви ведете демонстрацію екрана на другому рабочому столі, переключите на нього, щоб продовжити.
Окей.
Так.
Ще бачите чи не бачите мій екран?
Нас показує, що не прогружається.
Ланна Гордона запустила демонстрацію екрану. Нажміть двіжди, щоб вийти в полонкранний режим.
Ви запустили, але не дозапустили.
Будете знати, як на відповіді на питання не давати.
Та даюш, даюш. Так, я бачу свій екран, але чому ви його не бачите, не розумію.
Це екзамен від зуму, підтвердити вашу експертність в ньому.
100%! 100%! Ви знаєте?
Зупиніть демонстрацію. О, тепер можете запустити, і у вас вийде. Має вийти тепер.
Зупинила.
Пробуйте ще раз. Я вірю. Це вийде.
Ні.
Ну все. Амінь. Закінчуємо лекцію.
А у вас презентація почнуватися в іншому вікні?
Або ви запустите весь десктоп чи щось інше вибираєте?
Ні, весь десктоп.
А презентація ваша ось де воно?
Була відкрита, була відкрита.
Була відкрита.
А де, можливо, якщо я спробую запустити?
Тому що я тут нічого не нажимала, в принципі.
О, зараз видно.
Все, бачите?
Супер, все.
Значить, сесія з ідеалізацією клієнта.
Тут я хочу, щоб ви трошки погралися в парах, звісно.
Один учасник грає клієнта, який захоплюється коучем, постійно шукає схвалення, шукає схвалення.
Говорить, ви мене розумієте краще за всіх, без вас я б там не впоралася, не впорався.
Ну, ви знаєте, як можна ідеалізувати, так?
Як вважаєте, який тип особистості ось так може себе поводити на першій навіть сесії?
А ну-ка.
От якщо б ви пройшли всі тежні демобілі, от ви б знали.
таким з району цим поняттям з мого села ні Нарцистичний тип особистості так робить
зазвичай не можу сказати в нас в селі казали піздоли окей поїхали а значить завдання не під завдання
коуча висто витримати не підтримати цю залежність не посилати власну особливність не посилати
Не посилити власну особливість, не перейти у роль рятівника. Будемо старатися м'яко повертати клієнта до його ж автономії, не ставати, звісно, центром процесу та залишатися в етічній професійній пози
ції. Добре? Ось таке ось завдання.
Приклади питань. Бачите, скриньте собі. Акторську майстерність сьогодні відіграємо трошки. Заскрінили, так? Все, поїхали в практику.
Хочу побачити, як це можна зіграти і відіграти.
І як ви зможете з цим витримати.
Тому що такі люди зазвичай трапляються.
Добре, тоді 30 хвилин на практику.
І ось там, де Юлія Кравчук, Юра Спорище, ви таке раніше писали, Катерина.
Ви також слухачі, правильно? На ось цю практику.
Так.
Так, я вас розпределяю і додаю.
Набачу, щоб всі зайшли.
Не, не, я пока слухачів розпределяю.
Зали в відкритті.
Дякую.
Так, о, мені вдалося. Нашу маму тут і там показують.
Нічого собі у вас демонстрація екрану?
Що там? Я ж не особливо бачу. Я бачу, що мені сказало, а екран ж я у вас не бачу.
Це у вас потрібно, висвічується.
Це потрібно було зробити з самого початку.
Ні, все тільки зараз ось так ви поділилися екраном.
Перед цим ви були...
Так, з самого початку треба було так ділитися, було б гарніше.
Так, скидаю вам.
Якби на заднім фоном йде презентація, ось так.
О, клас!
А цікаво, якщо ви можете себе переміщати на інші сторони презентації,
тому що, бачите, тут виходить один, якби, там, блочок цей не видно.
А, отак можна, так, я вам теж скину, як виглядає.
Цікаво.
І так, також можна.
Так, насправді, просто маленька дуже презентація.
В третьому варіанті, так?
Так, так. Тобто, ваше віконечко і презентація, вони йдуть два, одразу видно.
І трохи малувати вікно презентації.
Ось так можна побачити, клас.
А це зум, оновлення зуму?
Так, я зрозуміла. Тут справа, віконечка, це оновлення зуму, і це дуже класно, і не треба брати додаткові дополнительні розрішення.
Ну, так, так як з телефону відображається, можливо зараз зайду, гляну також, як це видно з телефона, якщо в Zoom заходить.
Дякую за перегляд!
А можна мене, слушателям, в кімнату добавить? Я, навірно, не увидела приглашення.
Так, можна вставала вже.
Дякую, спасіба.
Так, добре. Іду дивитися, хто як грає, відіграє.
Я не віжу, може в телефоні не вдаю? Ага, віжу, все, спасіба.
Інчий аккаунт ваш просто додала. Я побачила.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
А повторять вам і не?
На, то можна?
Куда-куда можна?
Дякую за перегляд!
але але все все було дуже по прям по маслу Клас дякую я думаю аж там за вам Ні-ні-ні-ні я прям
слідкувала це було прям дуже-дуже-дуже мощно Клас особливо коли ви сказали мені зараз не
вистачає ось цього одного питання ще проситься ось прям от ви відчули Клас супер супер Аліна рада
бачити юля сьогодні включилась прям супер а ну розкажіть будь ласка що вдалося я знаєте
що помітила зараз хвилиночку я помітила що через гру вам вдається більше розкриватися
да через таку гру через визов окей юля що вийшлося розкажите
Я?
Що у нас получилось?
У нас получилась очень класная практика с Лерой.
І...
Да, я заметила.
Мене понравилось возвращать.
Мене понравилось быть в этой ролі коуча,
котрому потрібно вернуть,
где-то приостановити.
Мене с этим комфортно було.
Единственное, що я розумію, що в реальній житті ніхто не буде так тебе прямо.
Буде тебе! Буде! Буде! Конечно, це тріш.
Я далі, ви далі не були у нас в кімнаті. Лана, я далі Леру там, це просто.
Це був такий спектакль. І я кажу, у нас вже почалося ораторське іскусство.
Сьогодні просто ми вже починаємо підготовку перед завтрашнім днем.
Ну, взагалі, да.
Классо.
Видно сразу, що понятно, ну, це, як знаєте,
оно переводить фокус внимання,
оно сміщає відповідність.
Абсолютно.
І, воно, в цьому всім не варитися,
долу не слухати, ну, як я чувствую.
Тільки що сказали, ну вот интересно услышати от вас,
як це звучало, наскільки це правильно, да?
Я благодарю, мені приємно, але ми зараз о вас.
А давайте поговоримо о вас.
А що думаєте ви?
І вот такими фразами, якщо возвращать, наскільки це правильно,
і що ще може можна добавляти.
Я хочу, як ви, Лера, я хочу, як ви бути, я хочу бути, як ви.
Ну в одній з кімнат вообще сказали, в відпуск, я з вами хочу.
Главно, щоб не спати. А можна я з вами?
Так, абсолютно нормально. Юль, абсолютно нормально, коли ви так повертаєте.
Я розумію, але це історія про вас, наразі про вас.
Я хочу поговорити про вас, розкажіть більше про себе.
І повертаєте, звичайно такі люди чаще всього розказують о себе багато багато.
І дуже класно повернула в сесії з Еленою, класно повернула коуч, коли сказала, а розкажіть там про подруг, про ваше оточення, про ваше оточення і що ви там, яке у вас оточення.
І вона, коучі, почала розповідати про подруг, про те, що ну в мене є подружки, ну вони там так, сяк, там туди-сюди. І пішла б в особисту, в особисту життя. Тому так, так, от так повертайте.
Далі-далі по питанням, ви будете відчувати, як вам захочеться повертатися, знімати з себе ось цю відповідальність, яку клієнт хоче на вас навішати, що о, ви там щас рішите мій вопрос, я знаю, що ви з
робите щас самий лучший выбор, самий лучший результат, ви мені покажете, я знаю, я уверена в этом, я уверена, у вас такі годи практики, я виділа ваші кейсы,
і в ваших кейсах було стільки
всього, я уверена
просто, що і со мною ви сделаєте просто чудо.
Вот.
Такі бывають. Бывают такі клиенти, повірте.
Ой, як бывають, ще як.
Це не класичний коучинг,
як ви думаєте. Не завжди.
Це може бути тихо, спокійно про те, що там,
а як ти, а що ти відчуваєш,
а тра-та-та, і пошло-поїхало.
Не завжди це так. Не завжди.
Дуже цікаво буває, повірте.
Дякую, дякую. Класно було.
я дуже прямо насолодилася насолодилася Окей Василь Настя бачу Василь Лан я буду бігти
хочу тобі безмежно подякувати за цей рік що да ну от візьму чуть-чуть часу хочеш зніми відео
якщо хочеш може використати знімаю знімаю це не сценарно але факт а що там Клод вже написав
вже пост виставився все красиво ось я тобі можна говорити потім виріжеш я тобі хочу безмежно
подякувати за цей рік ти стала для мене от типу мамою коучингу і от твоя теплота кожне
твоє перегляд ну не знаю як в інші як мене сторіс коментар ти відграла дуже велику роль в
формуванні моєї ідентичності як коуча як ментора більше ніж коуча але то вже інше і знаєш на
одні із сесій ну коли я тут побачив наскільки ти глибоко бачиш не то що кому а півцяточки від коми
куди вона йде звідки вона йде і куди вона веде я в німножку в хорошому сенсі охренів там мало бути
і через гів і через у скільки мені ще рости і рости і реально яка ти крута тому я тобі дуже
дякую я буду бігти зраджувати тобі з хамамом я вже казав ось але дякую що ти є і далі буде
далі буде звісно звісно я бачу твій зріст і я бачу як ти трансформуєшся і я це бачу я бачу
свою трансформацію навіть якщо я не реагую або якщо не підписана на там когось з вас повірте я
бачу я бачу цей зріст якими ви прийшли і якими ви виходите але ваш шлях тільки починається в тому
початку в якому ви є неважливо це початок це кінець кінець чогось старого початок чогось нового
я бачу ці трансформації і це дуже для мене цінно дякую велике біжі біжіть зраджуйте зраджуйте мені з хамамом
не ревнуй добре дякую велика бай-бай дякую так хвилинка хвилинка щастя була дякую велика
Добре, йдемо далі по практиці, мені дуже приємно і дійсно я бачу кожного з вас, де кого можу побачити, я бачу, де встигаю, де не встигаю, я бачу
І це дуже класно, класно, класно, ви мої першачки, знаєте, як первенець мій в цій академії, знаєте, як первенець
Коли ви запам'ятовуєте всіх своїх дітей і ви всіх їх любите, але перші це ж найцінніше таке, прям, ух, клас, дякую, добре, по практиці поїхали далі, дякую велике, Нася, що вдалося?
Ми в комуніті просто насміялись від душі, просто у мене клуб.
Я рада, що мене вдалося вас, знаєте, так включити,
після тяжелого такого.
Насміялись, коли клієнт мені говорить, що ти найкраща, я кажу, да.
Я за вами стежу, я кажу, а я чуваю, що я вечірно інтуїтивно окна заштулююю.
це ви, це я от вас!
Ми насміялися дуже, тому що дійсно так подійшли к тому.
Але я розкажу вам ріальний свій кейс.
Коли ко мене гильшальтерапевт передала девочку на коучинг.
І она говорит, Настя, посмотри.
І дівочка прийшла і говорить, що мені мама дала кусочок бізнесів,
в полностью там контроль там нет сепарации бомбом и она мне говорит вот значит через 10 минут давайте
вы мне будете говорить что мне делать я буду это маме говорит что вы мне сказали так ну бизнес
вести как оно бывает я у нее спрашиваю расспрашиваю так хорошо что вы видите в этом бизнесе как вы
хотите там реализоваться она мне говорит ну вот вы мне скажете а я маме скажу а я говорю так я не
конкурент вашим ну как бы я не авторитетно для вашей мамы и для вашей мамы никто толку моё
слово для вашей мамы и вот этот весь процесс был до полтора часа диагностической сессии все и она
понятно что пошла дальше потому что она прям ну как бы прям психанула и обиделась потому что
Реально я говорю, так а смысл моє слово вашей маме?
Ну, кто я для нее? Никто.
Я для нее не авторитет.
Как вы это себе видите?
Я вот еще, знаете, не конкурировала с вашей мамой в слове за вас.
Ну, это моя мусль была, но я так і говорила.
То есть это реальные кейси, такое было.
Ну, они, видите, они уходят потом все.
Они приходят, они уходят.
Естественно, они задержатся, потому что полная инфантильность, детская позиция.
Какой там бизнес? Кто там будет?
Взрослых, и такое бывает, Настя, и у взрослых, и у зрелых людей.
Так їй 30, вона не дівачка, їй 30, це взросла жінка вже сформувавшись, а в кімнаті ми, звісно, оторвались по повній, я люблю іграти.
Супер, отлично, через ігри, сприймайте це життя як, знаєте, таку гру Алену Вхованки, сприймайте його так.
І, повірте, це дуже цікаво.
Це дуже цікаво.
Слованки.
Слованки тоже цікава ігра.
Коли ти кажеш дітям, так, діти потерялись, а я вас довго іщу.
Це теж гарніча ігра.
Так, дійсно так.
Добре. Лера, ваші стихи невероятні.
Ваші стихи невероятні.
Спасибо большое, услади, просто для моїх ушей.
Дуже було, дуже було, інтересно, трогательне, прям талант.
Супер. Ждемо вашу книгу.
Вера Поласкова.
Благодарю.
Супер. Окей, добре. Дякую велике.
Що ще вдалося? Дякую.
Іринка, що у вас вдалося? Чого ще питала?
Лена, Алина, чи були ви в залі?
То Олені треба запитатися, тому що, в принципі, ми почали працювати.
Так, і так, що спочатку якийсь запит, що все таке непонятно двоє.
а потім відпустили, і це в ролі ігри, і я навіть, знову ж таки, чому мені йде на менторство,
тому що мені по запитаннях, мені ще дуже важко мати центр,
я ніби вже бачу, куди оце ввести, через то менторство мені якось так, або, або, а давай тут,
і ось цьому мені легше, коли я даю якісь варіанти, направлення і якось так по них,
але із запитаннями ще дуже, якщо стартанути можна, але потім йти вглиб,
мені важко тут і це знову з Оленою мені показало та я потім потім пішло менторство і типу десь
воно надіювся що щось підсвітилося і що але трудно ще добре зрозуміло через то менторство
поки що поки що ще менторство моє так це ж прекрасно ви ж навчаєтесь на ментор коуча це
Це прекрасно, це прекрасно, все око.
Бо ось цим підтвердженням, тобто в мене є одна теж клієнтка,
в нас де менторство з нею, і вона якраз на початку в неї було постійно,
так як в неї мама померла, коли їй було 6 років, і вона ось це,
а правильно я роблю, а так, тобто вона прийшла, що в неї дуже сильний хаос,
і вона не знала, як почати інтегровуватися, мігровуватися,
було і вона каже я в хаосі і в мене просто скоро серце напевно трісне і вона підтвердження
завжди так тобто я правильно роблю а ось так і на сьогоднішній день типу ми вийшли на те що вона
втратила страх помилятися і я ніби їй стала як опорою де вона навіть якщо помилилася вона
приходить спокійно розповідає як досвід на якому грунтуються її нові кроки тобто що її ніби
Умовно, як я розумію, що її все рівно приймають, люблять, цінують і кажуть, ну, бачиш, як ти зробила, тобто ти тут молодець ніби, в такому плані, і вона таки вийшла з цього, тобто робить кроки вже, і
ось цього, я помічаю, нема.
А я правильно? А що ти скажеш? А що мені буде? А як це буде? Ну, тобто, в неї ось цих під час сесії якраз немає.
Але не коучингу, а менторством, бо ось цю стратегію вийшло взяти.
І на сьогоднішній день є результати.
Не знаю, наскільки це право.
Ірина, чи не стали ви її мамою?
Ні, тому що я слідкувала за цим і навіть з психологом типу якраз і йшла.
І ось це мені сказали, ти слідкуй, як вона?
Тобто, чи вона кроки робить, я зараз слідкую, чи вона кроки робить по своїй ініціативі, чи по моїй?
Тобто, вона сама каже, я це буду, вона йде по своїй ініціативі, але не по моїй.
Вона сама рефлексує, сама робить, з мого бачення, прослідкую ще, але мені ось це показує, що ні.
Тобто, що не я її веду, а я йду за нею.
Ні повертаю.
Повертаєте, автономність повертаєте.
Клас, супер.
Супер, дякую велике.
Олена Сідик, що вдалося в вас?
Нам вдалося попрацювати тільки в одну сторону,
тому що ізначально я взагалі там,
типа, запиту, начебто, нема, нема, нема.
А потім я згадала, в зв'язку за своїм бунтарем,
вчорашню свою історію, і це був реальний.
Вийшов запит. Зрозуміла, що я там впродовж все ж таки підігрувала в тому сенсі, що, боже, якщо ж вони не розумієте і так далі, але реально вийшов такий для мене серйозний запит, де...
Так, через гру, так? Через гру?
Ну, що добре, що я згадала саму цю історію, да, і дійсно, як би, розібратися в тому, чому я зробила так, а не так, як збиралася відначально.
Тобто, що мені завадило, все ж таки. Тобто, ну, трошки не допрацювали, але вже є над чим подумати.
Клас, супер. Чи побачили там, може, маску, може, захист якийсь у себе? Не відслідкували нічого? Які емоції? Може, емоції якісь, холодність, сухість або теплість? Щось таке відслідковували в себе? Чи
вдалося щось таке відслідкувати?
Я якось занурилася саме в запит, розмірковувала дійсно над питаннями Ірини і над своїми діями.
Ну і дійсно навагалася розібратися, що ж мене там зупинило.
Тому я саме за масками вже не слідкувала.
Тобто мені було важніше саме вирішити запит.
Процес. Процес. Процес.
Не стільки, скільки вирішувати, а сам процес.
Клас, все добре, супер.
Дивіться, що ми тут з вами ще робимо?
Я хочу, щоб ви просто звернули цю увагу на таку річ.
Ми тут з вами відслідковуємо те, що в реальних кейсах, в реальних запитах не завжди ми можемо побачити.
Тому що що? А, ми знаємо один одного тут.
Дуже класно вже знаєте.
Ага, ось, вам вже вільно, ви можете вільно спілкуватися, ви вже знаєте, і у вас і Б, і С, і так далі, у вас є вже на безсознательному рівні, що ви вчитесь, розумієте?
А коли ви будете виходити з просто незнайомою людиною, яка вам написала в дірект просто, а скільки коштує ваша сесія, ви такі там, не знаю, 100 євро, наприклад, бо там не знаю скільки, а я хочу, так,
а коли, все, назначаємо сесію, ми зустрічаємося, бачимося, там вже не буде цієї ролі.
Тому ми настільки на автоматизмі більше про рефлексію, настільки про, якщо ви звернете увагу також з першого по п'ятий модуль, я вчора перечисляла, було там про техніки, було про складні кейси, було
також про ігри, також ролеві ігри, складний клієнт, обурений клієнт і так далі.
Катерина Ентель з Юлією Печенка відробляли також дуже такий цікавий кейс був, коли Катерина була обурена дуже, Юлія її витягувала в автономію, коли ви мені должны, ви мені об'язані і все тому подобне
.
І з реальними кейсами такого вже не буде. Не буде часу відслідковувати. Тому ось ці сесії в кімнатах, що ми відігруємо, відробляємо зараз, це дуже цінно.
Дуже, от просто побачите цю цінність, тому що ви знаєте один одного, клас, все, ви вже друг з дружкою просто всі сконектились, і це неймовірно, бо ви всі цілком разом, ви просто сила селенна, немає
такого, у нас було в групі, коли я навчалася, 84 чоловіка було, 84, представляєте, це було капець просто, капець,
І кожного разу ти з новою людиною. І це не було 10 місяців, це було трошки менше на одному курсі, на другому курсі і так далі. Люди постійно мінялися.
І однієї сторони було класно те, що завжди нова людина, а з другої сторони не було стільки, знаєте, от прям верхушечок, як на Пасхі, знаєте, от тих конфеток не було, тому що людина нова і ти відпраць
овуєш з новою людиною, ти не знаєш її.
І не можеш продовжувати свій кейс, де ти все розповідала, ти маєш просто заново, заново, заново. Тут вже всі ви знаєте свої питання, хто про що, про як і як ви працюєте, як ви. Дуже злагоджено, скажі
мо так.
Тому що, ну, я не знаю, чи може виникнути якийсь сумнів, що, наскільки дає Академія, там, по знаннях, по сертифікації, по СІЄ цим годинам, але я вам точно скажу, вам вона дала силу, силу силенну в
качестві вас самих, в качестві вас самих, тому що ви тут прям собрались, ви знаєте вже манеру поведення кожного з вас.
Хто про що, хто про як, хто який. І ви всі дорослі. Дорослі, до яких ідуть люди за опорою.
Ви просто цю опору ще відробляєте в собі.
Ви тут можете казати, що ось десь я там гублю свою опору, десь я там щось не доробляю, щось не доцягую.
А якщо ви вийдете в мир к обичним людям,
ви ж просто, ну, блин, корона у кожного.
Просто скипетр, меч. Главное, щоб не Жанна Дарк.
Розумієте?
Ви вже настільки опорні самі з собою.
Це тут ми в рамках академії десь можемо трошки щось там відчувати,
якусь там нестійкість ще хочеться.
Тому що що? Тому що страх усудження,
Тому що порівняння є ще якесь, я там на когось хочу порівнятися, я там на когось так, дивлюся на вас, дивлюся на то, дивлюся на того викладача, на того викладача і так далі.
Це просто тому, що ви дивитесь на них, а коли ви подивитесь вже на себе, а на себе ви можете дивитися в соціумі.
Те, що я казала вчора, в соціумі, коли ви виходите до незнайомих людей,
там ви аналізуєте і дивитесь в соціумі, як ви себе поводите.
Як ви себе поводите. Що ви знаєте? Просто на автоматі аналіз.
Головне не губитися. Не растворяться. Не растворяться все.
Добре, клас, запам'ятали? Запам'ятали, запам'ятали мені, поїхали далі.
Нам Влада теж цього дня казала, що ви вже і Діані Ковчі.
Абсолютно, абсолютно, не знаю, що там Влада казала, а я вам кажу, своє, не була у вас на сесії.
Але ми в один голос говоримо, мабуть всі викладачі.
Так, поїхали далі, в нас ще є одна практика, але що хочу сказати, зараз, що хочу вам сказати, так, сесія ідеалізували, супер, клас, ідеалізували, дуже смачно ідеалізували, цінно, звісно, цінно, ви
самоцінність, ви самоцінність, золоті горшики тут.
Так, бачимо очікуваний результат, досліджувати тему владу та ідеалізації, вчитися підсилювати залежність клієнта, не підсилювати, вчитися не підсилювати, помічати власну реакцію та захоплення на зах
оплення клієнта, як ви захоплюєтесь цим клієнтом, інтегрувати більш зрілу етичну позицію.
Ви це зробили. Всі зробили. Всі, абсолютно всі зробили.
Так, блок третій. Як ми завершуємо стосунки з клієнтом?
Як ми завершуємо? Як ми завершуємо?
Це одна з найменш обговорюваних тем.
Найменш завершення професійних стосунків.
Але я хочу її торкнутися.
Саме завершення часто показує, наскільки зрілою є професійна позиція коча.
Дивіться, я вже не знаю, два-три модулі, я говорю про зрілість, зрілість, зрілість, зрілість, ще раз зрілість. З самого початку селф-дискавері говорила про опору в собі, про контакт з собою, як ви з
собою контактуєте. Чому? Іноді, іноді завершення буває складним.
Клієнти там їдуть, уходять кудись, ідуть, зникають клієнти, розчаровуються, можливо, клієнти, можливо, ви відчули, що вони розчарувалися, переростають коуча навіть, або більше не потребують процесу.
Ось Настя сказала, одна сесія, все, процес вже завершився. І це може викликати, може, це не завжди, а може викликати у спеціаліста якусь тривогу, образу вже не хочу говорити про образу, не може тут
викликати, але десь в душі щось ви можете відчути на якусь мить.
Це не про глобалізацію якоїсь образи. Якийсь може викликти сумнів у собі, бажання утримати клієнта, щось йому там сказати, або може також викликти відчуття власної значності, втрати власної значущост
і.
Також в психології супервізії це розглядається як attachment dynamic, in professional relationship. Що це значить? Розказую, зріле завершення. Коли коуч розуміє, що клієнт йому не належить?
Завдання коуча не створити таку довгострокову прив'язаність, а допомагати людині бути автономною, бути усвідомленою, здатною рухатись самої далі без постійної опори на спеціаліста.
І коли коуч має завершити процес? Іноді сам коуч має визнати, що процес більше не рухається. І ми можемо самі сказати клієнтові, що дивись, Любий, не знаю, Петро або Маріка, я бачу, що ми тут вже зав
ершили, з чого ми будемо починати за наново, якщо ти хочеш.
і як ми будемо відбудовувати стосунки далі.
От у нас є блок, допустим, ти там оплатила 5 сесій,
ми завершили ці 5 сесій, окей, хочу розуміти,
давай повертаю тобі за 5 сесій всю абсолютно цінність,
де що ти побачила, де зрушилась з міста,
і хочу розуміти, куди ми будемо рухатися далі,
чи має це сенс для нас, тому що процес може більше не рухатись.
І це теж ок.
Але коучу важливо отак схватити цей процес
і зрозуміти, куди далі вести клієнта.
Не просто так, ну що, ми будемо продовжати?
А куди ми будемо продовжати?
А навіщо будемо продовжати?
Також іноді сам коуч має визнати, що виникла залежність.
Таке теж буває.
Що клієнту потрібен інший формат допомоги.
Також говорила про це вчора.
Якщо є якийсь спеціаліст, який може гешталь, трошки схемотерапію попрацювати,
ви знаєте, що ви з цим не працюєте, або якісь клінічні діагнози,
або клієнт у вас підсвідомив на п'ятій сесії, сказав,
а я на антидепресантах, і що ви далі будете робити?
От скажіть мені, будь ласка, рукою, що ви далі будете робити,
якщо вам клієнт на п'ятій сесії каже,
Він каже, а ви знаєте мене, ви помічаєте, що з клієнтом щось не так.
Давайте вб'ємо тих, через кого ти тут сидиш, на них.
Буває таке, що клієнт каже, а ви знаєте, я там сижу, короче, і ще аземпік ще приймаю, я схудну таку хочу.
ось і ще в мене амітрептіліни там є 50 міліграм ось і все і от і от ви розумієте що там хитає
Юрій недоречно ось і ось я вам не я вам маю зізнатися от ви маєте знати ось ну це там буквально 25
міліграм і вообще все ок все ок і все прийшов до коуча тому що що тому що на рапорті ви
Ви сказали, що ми прозріст, і він, клієнт, каже, я хочу рости.
Я хочу рости, все, там все клас, я там антидепресіантики поп'ю трошечки, і все, іду далі.
От що ви робите?
Ваші припущення?
Все вірно, що скажете, що я почую, я поправлю, якщо що.
Так, Юля.
Ну, це, типу, не на першій сесії, якщо.
Типу, я не бачу в цьому проблему взагалі, мало ли що він там приймає, ну хай приймає, це підтримуюча терапія, якщо він відчуває готовність працювати, якщо ми працюємо і ми бачимо результат,
якщо він відчуває потребу працювати з коучем і ми працюємо і бачимо результат, то чому ні?
Тобто я так думаю, що це може бути паралельно, паралельно з антидепресантами, я не знаю про зимпік, таких подробностей, що він там робить з людьми.
зімпіг просто тому і голод ти просто менш хочеш їсти схуднення схуднення я знаю це я знаю я не знаю як він впливає на психіку
ні як побачок нема відсутності апетиту
ну от ну що ж вона приймає ну хай приймає
інша справа якщо ми бачимо що це початок прийому антидепресантів і вона себе погано почуває це тільки вхід то там може бути воно так не дуже приємно
і може людина бути і не до того не до розвитку це точно то може треба перечекати я б ще не знаю
може там я перепитала чи працює вона з терапевтом додатково чи чи працює з терапевтом
чи це зараз доцільно, чи немає від лікаря якихось, може, що їй не треба зараз,
чи від терапевта, що, може, їй не треба зараз йти в розвиток,
бо це може її ще більше заводити в якісь депресивні стани,
через те, що ми наплануємо, поставимо план, вона не виконає,
і почне впадати ще більше в такі депресивні состояния.
Да Юлія регулювана я сказала приклад амитрептилін 25 мг вона приймає амитрептилін я не знаю що це
виведете клієнта виведете клієнта це вже там четверта-п'ята сесія він каже та 25 мг амитрептилін короче
а ви помітили що з клієнта щось там руханка якась не така вже що щось не так щось він
Ви його питаєте, а що там і як, як ти себе почуваєш, бачите в роздраї трошки, бачите там, що з тобою, що з тобою сьогодні.
Він кажете, ви знаєте, то ось не виспалася я там, тра-та-та, і взагалі хотіла вам сказати, я приймаю амитріпцілін, це регульовано, все ок, але це просто для мене, щоб регулювати свій стан.
от я готова працювати далі це ось так от ну короче тимчасово все буде ок
я вже включила чат депіті що це амитріптілі о перше що ви зробите це побачите що це за
Препарат, про який вам кажуть клієнти, дезіровка, і навіщо вона його приймає.
Вам не об'язательно це знати.
Ви має клієнти, дітей, усіх і навіть кота. Не знаю, до чого коментар? Але ладно.
Тобто вам необязательно знати клініку, вам клієнт прийшов за ростом і от він такий, не всі кажуть, що антидепресант є.
Ми дивимося на те, як він себе поводить, чи є в нього результат, правильно? Ну а то, що він там приймає, яка різниця?
може в терапію з ним не йдемо може його не терапевтуємо по суті це таке цікаво почути вашу думку вже
добре дякую давайте послухаємо ще там було дві руки Настіна і Олена Настя
Я завжди поінтересуюся, що говорить врач по поводу, який назначив лекарства, що він рекомендує нагрузки, наприклад, в реалізація наше буває разна.
І опять же, запрос буває разний, він приходить в цей момент не в запрос, а, наприклад, працюватися з внутренним конфліктом, чи ще щось.
і тут, і тож не тільки про достиження, як коуч-коуч приходить з разными, і тут питання, що говорить врач, що рекомендує врач, то есть я спрашиваю, що говорить тот терапевт?
Говорить, нічого не говорить психотерапевт, що він може сказати, просто выдав мне лікарю.
І потім, коли чоловік озвучить запрос, точно також спрашиваю, є ли на це ресурси.
Тобто я смотрю і діагностирую, є ли на це ресурси і спрашиваю.
Тобто желаний може бути огромний, вопрос ресурсов.
Есть на це время, ресурсы, настроение, силы.
Реально ли це зараз, в даній ситуації, в даному моменті?
То есть він може не соответствувати.
Запроси желания можуть не соответствувати реальности,
то, що це можна сейчас.
То есть тут і тут і тут діагностирується.
Як ви считаєте, що ви должны, о чому ви должны уведомити клієнта?
Должны ли ви о чому-то уведомити клієнта?
Настя, запрос к вам. Должна ли ви уведомляться?
Ну, що і може бути, і зараз це не відповідає реалі, його поставлю на цей запрос.
Що може додати?
Можете по факту зараз?
Я все можу, я на антидепресантах, у мене все буде стабильно, у мене все буде добре.
ну тут вопрос да тогда человек озвучивает что он будет и как он будет и потом смотрится в динамике
то действительно так или нет это если следующий будет еще сессии возможности том что нет у вас
не получится я тоже говорить нет смысла я ж не знаю действительно что он может а что он не может по
факту ну и о себе постоянно то есть если человек там настроена только на только реализацию и
і не буде в графіці, а заботи о себе, і точно також, що...
Ну, я все равно спрашиваю, що говорив врач.
Я досконально буду спрашивати.
Ну, психіатр, мало що говорять.
Там встречи один раз в місяць.
У вас встречи, як минимум, 4 за цей місяць.
Ну, то тоже, да, не завжди.
Ну, опять же, в динамике смотришь,
что, ну, хорошо, человек сказал,
я это могу, я все могу,
и вот это могу, и это могу.
И еще раз мы отфильтровали,
действительно ли может человек,
и смотришь, в следующую сессию,
действительно, что может, что нет.
И самочувствие, а как самочувствие,
а как прошло, то есть неделя все равно идет.
Постоянно коннект.
Окей, хорошо.
Услышала вас.
Спасибо большое.
Олена Сідик, що скажете?
Для мене, во-первых,
немножечко непонятно про зенпек.
Імеє ли смысл обращати на це увагу?
Так.
А з приводу
таблеток, які прописал
психіатр, да?
Якщо б,
наприклад, я бачила, що
ми проговарюємо якісь діювання, а діювання не діються, і кліент потім віддає мені, що він сидить на таблетках, то я б якби більше, наверное, спрашивала про те, зв'язуває ли він ці два фактора, да?
Тому що йому складно робити ті діювання і таблетки, які він прийняє.
І якщо б він мене почав увернути, що все добре, все добре, все добре, я тут готова і все таке, то я тут все равно б над цим пунктом бачила і просила б його його теж об цьому, що якщо йому по яким-то
причинам сложно випадять те чи іні действия, щоб він правдив об цьому.
І, можливо, якби, стоїть встановитися на якийсь період часу, поки він не війде в іншу фазу, і тоді можна повернутися про все реалитися.
Супер, спасибо большое. Есть ще мнение?
Юра, що ви будете робити, якщо к вам клієнт так скажет?
Чиєво? Добре.
Даліна?
Я думаю, що я б, наверное, приглашив клиенту пройти курс,
який му назначив психотерапевт і потім вернутися, щоб ми з тобою роботали, коли твоя психіка восстановиться.
Ну, психіатр, ну, імейте віду курс, просто курс антидепресантів?
А не все время на них сидять, а не периодически.
Буває, тоді годами сидять?
Ну, якщо б я бачила, що, наприклад, шагів немає,
ніяких результатів немає, ну я б, наверное, відказалася от такого клієнта,
тому що, ну, тут не буде результатів, виновата буду я,
моя сама оцінка упадеть нижу плинтуса, що я не справилась,
на самом деле, ну, і обратну енергию я б не получила, да?
Ну, як-то так.
С массажами у мене так.
Якщо я вважаю на третєм сеансі результата нет,
ми прощаємся.
Окей.
Спасибо большое, Лена.
Настя хотіла додавати щас, минути.
Катя.
Катя, ентель.
Ну, по идеї,
ми додожні уточнити,
скільки він приймає?
25 міліграмів.
Нет, не дозіровка, а по времени.
Якщо він тільки почав, то, понятне, що ти нічого не будеш.
Який психіатр поставив діагноз?
Якщо це депресія, с якими-то тривожними розладами,
то ми не можемо нічого від нього требувати.
Ми розуміємо, в якому зараз знаходиться в состояниї пацієнт, клиент.
І вже к чому-то двигатися, як говориться, к яким-то цілям, ми можемо в 4-6-ї неділи, коли антидепресант почнє дійсною дійсною, це якщо брати в роботу.
Психіатр, він же, да, ми видімося з ним один раз в місяць, і, в будь-якому випадку, в будь-якому випадку должна бути підтримка і терапія.
Якщо клієнт ходить к психологу, він ходить к психологу, він продовжує терапію, а не просто приймає антидепресант, точно так же этой терапією може бути коуч.
Ми можемо дуже мягко говорити про ціли, про якісь движення, як він буде по чуть-чуть двигатися, навіть з момента, помутий лише голову чи ні.
Ну, це теж про цели і про движення. І при цьому ти контролюєш клієнта по його емоціональному, психологичному состоянию, смотриш динамику, наскільки він там проваливається чи нет.
І, ну, це теж як такий легкий мониторинг, тому що після начала приєму антидепресантів, після неділи, теж у нас вже може бути відкат, і теж це як підтримка.
Тому бачать клієнта, ну, кожен робить вибір, але, опять же, можна знайти тактику, чем ти будеш полезен на цьому етапі для клієнта.
Дякую.
Настя, ще до дозвітаємо?
Я теж хотіла сказати, що
відбувається все і може бути все
і дійсно тарапіюється.
Але при цьому люди підлядіють
і реалізовуватися.
Йому потрібно підходити їх графіки,
відео відбувається.
І в цьому теж може бути моя робота.
Тому, що
ми можемо ставити графіки,
ми можемо ставити якісь дедлайни,
Такі прості, що ми можемо делегіровати.
Точно також навчить клієнта делегіровать задачи,
сняти якогось відповідність, як це зробити правильно.
Тож в допомогі в цьому коучі.
Тут треба просто дивитися.
І, опять же, якщо відкатуватися, то подіжати, і тут все ок.
І так приходить за цим клієнт, що і тут тож все ок.
Дивіться, дійсно це так, тому що що? Тому що я вже казала, і на попередніх лекціях також казала, що ми не завжди про той результат, який ми собі там десь в голові, в голіванці закрутили, що там біз
нес треба відкрити, або людей треба набрати, або досягнути, заробити 100 тисяч, мільйон і так далі, і так далі, і так далі.
Да, дійсно, люди можуть бути на антидепресантах, на низьких дозіровках, коли дійсно вони розуміють, що навіть якщо там 50 міліграм, вони розуміють, що я не хочу зараз в психотерапію, я хочу там в ко
учинг, бо коуч може бути мотиватором, коуч може мотивувати, мотивувати абсолютно вірно, помити голову, мотивувати піти на прогулянку, мотивувати повернутися до себе,
десь собі дозволити, або мотивувати на зал, на тренування якесь, на прогулянки, далі, далі, далі.
І це дійсно відстежується в динаміці протягом декількох тижнів або місяців.
Все залежить від того, звісно, коли ця людина вже почала приймати антидепресанти.
Людина каже, от я п'ю вже антидепресанти з моменту, як почалася оця повномасштабна.
як у нас почалася ця історія, цей конфлікт.
І, звісно, з цього моменту я не можу себе опинувати і не маю мотивації.
Розумію, що я не хочу в психотерапію, ось коучинг для мене, не знаю, навчилася,
ви мені сподобались, ви так класно мене можете мотивувати,
ви така класна, ви сама класна, в принципі, я хочу бути такою класною, як ви.
Бо ви там маєте таку силу, і це не про гроші,
це не завжди про гроші, це не завжди про бізнес,
це не завжди про щось, якісь там построєння чогось,
там, якихось пірамід, розумієте?
Це може бути дійсно мотивацією.
Звісно, якщо людина там з біполярно-афективним розтруйством
і дійсно там сидить на сертраліні вже,
то есть це вже нейролептики,
і там трошки складніше може бути.
І це тільки для вас, працюєте ви з цим чи не працюєте.
Бо такий клієнт сьогодні може сказати вам привіт,
а завтра може сказати, идіть ви нам, понимаєте?
От, і таке теж може бути, може бути.
Тому що психіка нестабільна. Все залежить від того, тобто, по-перше, ми для себе це не завжди маємо знати, бо ми говоримо зараз про коучинг, ми не говоримо про психотерапію, ми в першу чергу монітор
имо, що це за препарат, які дозіровки, помімо того, що питаємо у клієнта, що це за препарат, які дозіровки, бо зараз дуже багато людей сидить на антидепресантах, ну дуже багато людей.
На виписаних лікарем, психіатром. Також дуже багато людей сидить на магній, на величезних дозіровках є таке, де є сонливість. Просто приймають тисячу міліграм один раз на день і як сонна мушка там
просто себе відчуває.
5-HTP, адаптол, наш мебікар. Це безрецептурні препарати, які також можуть трошки підторможувати клієнта. Про все питаємо. В першу чергу питаємо про все. Чи є у вас медикаментозне якесь лікування? Які
вітаміни ви п'єте? А може людина не спить взагалі, люди? Розумієте?
може людина не спати, може вона спить там 2-3 години,
а вона виглядає свіжечком, а спить вона 2-3 години.
І ви розумієте, що її план, тобто ця звірка, вона має бути,
звіритися з її станом, не як ти себе почуваєш,
а скільки ти спала, скільки ти спиш на тиждень, скільки ти їсиш,
чи є в тебе спорт, чи є в тебе медикаменти.
Щось таке треба базово звірити.
Я рекомендую це звіряти.
Щоб ви розуміли більше стан клієнта. Потім на тестування з Ненсі Маквіліем розумієте, який там психотип преобладує, а може не преобладує. І далі вже трошки більше знаєте про свого клієнта, навіть
більше, ніж він сам про себе знає.
І пішли, поїхали далі його або мотивувати, або рухати, наприклад, до якоїсь точки Б.
Так? Дякую велике.
Так, дівчатка в мене тут пересміюється.
Що там смішного? Розкажіть мені. Больше двох говорять, слух говорять.
Я віжу, віжу все. Все віжу, все слышу, навіть через екран.
Аліна, говори.
Мене Настя в цьому, в діректі-коучі, напала на мене.
Антидепресанти? Ні, вона вже кілька разів мене дресірує, бо тренує, тут не підходить.
Вона дресірує в плані відповіді клієнтам, скільки коштує моя сесія, яка сесія, скільки, чому вона так, то мені дорого,
ну тобто вона мене прощупує менторів просто Ланна я перепрошую це не то що ми прекрасно
вас чуємо це просто два ардушніка зібрались які ж не можуть щось одне робити ми чуємо я
особисто абсолютно все чую я теж всього увагу навіть в присутстві просто спомняв що переб'ю
Скористаюся можливістю. Мій коментар був до того, як я завершую сесії з клієнтом.
А, і тебе, і чоловіка, і маму, і діда, і кота.
Я снігла собі маю. Ми на цю тему з вами говорили вже, Аліна.
Дякую, Лана.
Добре, поїхали далі. Клас. Обійматися треба менше в сесіях з клієнтом.
Окей, поїхали. Так, в нас. Далі. Ми зрозуміли, коли коуч має завершити процес, де іноді саме коуч має визнати якісь моменти, де контакт перестав бути корисним, або завершити процес завершаємо, або ан
тидепресанти налякали, або дали якусь таку хитку мнення, думки, що ой, а що з тобою ділить далі, що ти там на антидепресантах сидіш.
Тобто таке треба виясняти. Далі, фінальна інтеграція професії. На завершення програми вашої, коли ви завершуєте програму з сесії з клієнтами, важливо також не лише вміти проводити сесію, звісно, і
розуміти, в першу чергу також розуміти, яким я спеціалістом хочу бути через роки, що я хочу нести у цю професію,
що я не хочу втратити і як залишитися живою людиною всередині цієї роботи на протязі років.
Ми таку рефлексію з вами проходили, так, ось, по-моєму, в шостому модулю ми проходили таку рефлексію,
що я хочу нести у цю професію, у своїй професії, як я бачу себе через роки, яким коучем, яким спеціалістом бачу чи не бачу, можу і не бачити.
Далі в нас третя фінальна практика на сьогодні, але по часу бачу, що ми скоро підемо на перерву. Ага, в нас вона по 10-20 хвилин. Ми встигаємо, потім будемо говорити. Ми встигаємо практику до перерви
зробити. Клас, так, супер.
Добре, тоді пишіть, будь ласка, хто готовий, яким коучем я хочу залишитися через руки практики, тут рефлексійна така практика, можете погратися, можете ось через гру собі, знаєте, додати щось, що я
хочу бачити в собі, як я хочу бачити в собі, якою я хочу бачити себе і так далі, і так далі.
От, задача коуча – створити простір для чесної професійної інтеграції. Тобто інтегруйте все. Я хочу заробляти 100 тисяч, я хочу 500 тисяч, я хочу мільйон заробляти, я хочу бачити вже свою клініку, а
бо я хочу бачити свій кабінет, або я хочу там десь в цьому місці.
Давайте трошки таке привнесемо, трошки більше, не на рівні такої фантастики, а трошки більше. Прям дозвольте собі порефлексувати наповну за 10 хвилинок, що я хочу, яким коучем я хочу залишитися через
роки практики.
Навіть побачте своє оточення, свою сім'ю, де я в цьому коучингу. Добре? Попробуйте, просто проекспериментуйте, побачте свою людяність, власні принципи, межі, страхи, цінності, професійний вибір. Це
прям тут generally написано, але ви для себе візьміть те, що прям для рефлексії.
яким коучем ти не хочеш стати, так далі, так далі.
Питання, приклади беріть, якщо потрібні.
Так, скріньте собі, якщо потрібні.
Але ці питання, вони такі, генералізовані.
Ось, спробуйте йти зсередини, от прямо зсередини.
Популярно я хочу бути, непопулярно і так далі, і так далі. Добре?
Окей, поїхали.
Я розпреділяю слухачів.
Дякую.
Просто зараз дозвольте собі побути в цьому.
От ви завершили 10 модулів вже.
Дозвольте собі побути пофантазувати.
Дякую за перегляд!
і підскажіть повторіть на скільки хвилин робимо кімнати 20 всього 20 хвилин так
все можна заходити дякую Юлічка
Дякую за перегляд!
Дякую.
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую за перегляд!
Я чесно, це просто моя роль по житті. Я не дуже звикла, щоб до мене просто кричали і питали, коли я щось зроблю.
Коли? Коли? Давай, дати.
Ми вже все домовилися. 27 мая.
Я вже навіть записала себе в ежедневник, да, Аліна? Потім я перезваниваю, да, Алін? І спрашиваю, ну шо?
про і фото і відео цей чого требує да в мене всі аб'юзери я куди не повернуся мене всі грома б'юзять
і вкладачка у вас дуже строго да да да да добре це просто не конфузить якщо часто
добре що ж вияснилось совершенно недавно я люблю дружитися временем особливо з різницею
в дві годинки, але це нічого, ми все одно вже завершуємо.
Ми завершили вже з вами ці 10 модулів, цей великий професійний цикл
і працювали зі всім, із присутністями, із складними станами,
і грали, і вивчали, і досліджували, і ми розуміємо себе як спеціаліста,
ви вже знаєте, що ви є, ви вже є цілі, цілосні,
Ви вже не питаєте себе, хто я, чим я хочу займатися, давай розкажу, а хто ти, а де ти, а що ти.
Ви вже знаєте прекрасно, хто ви, що ви і де ви. Ви все це розумієте.
Ми сьогодні вже розібрали професійну маску, які маски можуть бути, ідеалізацію коуча,
як коуча можуть ідеалізувати, як зріло завершати стосунки з клієнтами, проговорили.
Професійну зрілість як здатність не отримувати клієнта поруч з собою, також розуміємо, свої цінності, і яким коучем ви хочете залишитися через роки практики.
Ви розумієте, це все. Я дуже-дуже рада, що в вас виросла така неймовірна опора. І я дуже вдячна вам. Вмикаєте всі свої камери. Хочу цей момент, якщо є можливість, хочу запечатлеться, як то кажуть.
Розумію, що кожен з вас сьогодні вже дуже втомився. Ви дуже втомилися за всі ці 10 модулів, 11 місяців навчання. Я це розумію, як ніхто другий. Я вам скажу так, але це ще не завершення.
Це ще не завершення. Трошки передихнете і знову в путь, знову ізучати якісь інструменти, знову себе розширювати і знову себе удосконалювати. Тому що професія допомагаюча, вона така необ'ятна, вона
дуже обширна.
Тому я дуже вам вдячна за це, що ви були тут зі мною, я була з вами в цілковитої присутності і моя серденько з вами буду вже сумувати за вами. Кого бачу, буду слідкувати далі, побачимо, який професій
ний або непрофесійний розвиток у вас буде.
і бажаю вам найкращого реалізації у всьому стосунках професії з клієнтами, з собою в першу чергу.
Сьогодні вам дуже рекомендую, може, якесь побачення з собою, знаєте, собі влаштувати
і відмітити цей день як дуже визначний день у вашому житті.
я зайшов спеціально попрощатися можемо маємо дві хвилинки якщо є слово непрощальними
не прощаємося з вами дуже дякую вам всім Даліночка дуже не хотілося чути ті слова
правда ви говорите мене такий супротив реально не хочеться їх чути і прям аж сльози не
протаю це на очі бо того що ну не знаю ну от вам вдається створити атмосферу не навчальну
так а це реально атмосфера такого розширення внутрішнього розширення по-перше ну і відповідно
професійно професійне розширення вже йде як бонус кіпа ти вже там маєш той той той той той
Інструмент, але в першу чергу розширення саме як особистості.
І це просто безцінно. Я не знаю, я цей рік, для мене, напевно, один з найкращих років мого життя.
Тому що я провела його просто в неймовірній атмосфері, з неймовірними класними людьми.
І дуже надіюсь, що ми продовжимо в інших якихось форматах.
Люблю усіх. Вас, Лана, дуже, ну, прям, взагалі, просто обожнюю.
Знаєте, ви отка собі неповторна.
Ви ні на кого не схожа.
І це прям настільки притягує.
Дякую вам велике за те, що ви так з теплотою, з любов'ю і з душею викладаєте цей предмет.
Дякую вам.
Дякую, що стала частиною вашого життя.
Мені дуже приємно. Це для мене честь.
Частиною кожного з вас. Дякую.
Да, Леночка Гавриленко.
Ну, я, конечно, хочу сказать большое, огромнейшее спасибо, да,
это от чистого сердца, потому что, действительно, тема очень интересная.
Я всегда была интересна эту тему, да, и вот мой жизненный опыт,
мой профессиональный опыт, оно было все вот так вот в одну шкатулочку сброшено, да,
и вот благодаря вот этим вот обучениям, оно все, все разложилось по полочкам,
я теперь закрыла рот я не бегу не осчастливлю никого я не даю советы то есть я прожила
практически с вами свою колегу слава богу все пришло в норму я теперь даже ее повадки начинаю
брать то есть вот я только что свете говорила вот она проходит она сказала в моей кабине кто-то
был и пошла дальше а я за ней побежала то есть вот у меня сейчас принцип я сказала тебе надо ты
меня догониш это вообще ну то есть вообще ну у меня нет слов остались эмоции то есть очень
классно огромнейшее спасибо всем спасибо всем преподавателям всей группе то есть ну вообще
очень круто класс очень тепло очень тепло душевно благодарю благодарю каждого из вас вижу ваш рост
і ще раз до нових зустріч, ми не прощаємося, ще побачимося з Вами.
Та ні, стойте, ми ж прощаємося, в смысле не прощаємося, ми не як на похоронах прощаємося,
але як на обучення ми прощаємося.
Завершився тільки навчальний цикл.
Ну так, ми прощаємо навчальний цикл, віддайте честь цьому моменту, насолодіється ним,
кожне прощання має свою особливу ностальгію, дайте її відчути, не блокуйте свої емоції.
Насолодіться цим моментом.
Ви заради чого вчилися цим моментом?
Щоб проживати емоціями, щоб блокувати їх?
Що ви їх блокуєте?
Тобто тобі Одеса не світить в сентябрі, а нам — так.
Одеса, мама.
А що ви думаєте, війна не закінчиться?
Ви отакі песимісти.
От так от ви думаєте, до неньки свої України відноситься, так?
А я вірю, що війна закінчиться.
Ми з вами в Одесі погуляємо.
І нехай це буде моєю вірою, поки це не стане правдою.
правдою Амінь нехай нехай так і буде нехай так і буде чекаємо чекаємо дякую дякую велике Юрій
насолоджуюсь насолоджуюсь і приймаю і я забігаю навіть наперед що кажу що ми з вами ще побачимося
і на просторах нашого життя ми ще зустрінемося обов'язково з кожного я це не вірю оце оце я
так не люблю це розносити знається як люди деколи я з деколи з кимось можу прощатися я розумію
що ну тіпа люди хочуть побачити дуже багато було зустрічі де було це що люди хочуть побачити людям
було кайфово але деколи часто треба признати що це остатня зустріч от і ми вірні що буде наступна
земля квадратна на углу зустрічимся не переживай Господа Боженько роднеї душі близько
добренько Дякую всім велике за присутність дякую вам за вашу силу а давайте щоб це трошки
я спеціально заради цього моменту зійшов звісно я тільки за задоволенням зустрінусь я
кажу я можу зустрітися можу прилетіти до Болгарії до Румунії до України буду в вересні
Я з 23 по 30 я буду в Стамбулі гулять сама зі своїм СММщиком а з 30 по 8 я буду в Батумі гулять сама зі своїм СММщиком присоединяйтесь
як сама або зі своїми СМІМ щиками в смыслі сама і свої свої СМІМ щось якщо можна і контент я
типу намекаю контента можна напілити дати влічку дати влічку дати влічку кидайте
добре що ж прощаємося прощаємося на сьогодні все на сьогодні все Наталочка Нуца Татяна Артемова
Юлія Споріш Маша Храб всіх просто обіймаю всіх-всіх-всіх безмежно на зв'язку
на зв'язку всім на зв'язку дякую гарного я розширований нашим прощанням дякую дякуємо дякуємо
дякуємо дякуємо Юрій встретимося що я його не підтримую дякую вам дуже лану я протестую
з Ладою було цікавіше там реально було якось оце проживало це прощання всі якось
Ви можна вже давно піти? Дякую, Оленечка, все, на зв'язку, на зв'язку, побачимось на випускному.
До побачення. Ужас, уваж, не вмієте прощатися, не побачите вам. Юрка, йди вже.
В цьому моменті, знаєте, коли ти на вокзалі, проведаєш свою людину і розчаровуєшся, що поїзд їде, але ця мать була неїзбежною, і ти розумієш, що поїзд їде, хоч якусь сльозу пустила, хоч тримаю вашу
увагу, ви так само цього хочете, я ж тримаю вашу увагу, Юра, чому це важливо для тебе зараз?
У мене важливо, що це останній момент, це единний момент, який так може бути.
Ми ні разу не попрощались нормально за все це час, а тут останній момент, останній можливості.
Юрич, я взагалі портию квитів.
Красоту. Це не мої ціли. Це не мої ціли, це загадка.
Так, так, так.
Я ж казав, що у мене іноді люди платять за ціли ціли, не мені.
І це був той самий случай, я рішил показати примером, як це може бути.
Я не люблю розказувати, я люблю лучше розказувати.
Ти не мої, а через мене, чи боженька захотела, так пусть і считаєте.
Загадка. Подписана Вами?
Подписана, да. Ну я сказав, що вот таку, пожалуйста, записочку.
Що таке амурфати? Раскажіть на прощання, що таке амурфати?
Ти сто раз розповів, що це?
Я ні разу не розповів.
Але що це переводиться як якась там життя?
Не, не, це смысл життя?
Нет, амурфати не смысл життя.
Ну, розкажіть.
Ладно, розкажіть, що для вас амурфати?
Раскажіть ви мені тепер.
Дуже мені подобається моменту морі. Моменту морі — це признати, що життя конечна, що є момент, який настанет останнім.
Ось тут більше моменту морі. І ця цінність момента в тому, що ти розумієш, що життя наша скончаємо, і від цього ти оціниш кожен момент.
Тому ти оттягиваєш цей процес, вже смотрий, як можеш цього моменту.
Моменту морі тут більше йдет, а не аморфати. Аморфати — там інший смысл, важний.
Юрсь, не осознайся, що тебе грустні всіх. І все, і ми поїдемо.
Мене дуже грустно.
Ось цю і грущу.
Ми вас обнимаємо. Юря, ми вас обнимаємо.
Ми вас обнимаємо.
Була б Алина, она поцеловала б твоєго кота.
А так, извините.
Юра, єдинствено, який не верить, що ми зустрічаємося.
Ну, пусть не верить. Пусть це буде сюрприз.
Знаєш, коли чоловік не верить, а тут раз сюрприз. Ну, класний.
Це додавляє моменту радості.
Да. А так, що ж вигорання приходить.
А вот це ожидання того, що не наступить, це тільки розтрає.
Тому краще попрощаться со спокійною душою, жити себе далі.
А потім, якщо життя, судьба подарить тебе цей момент,
Ти будеш, безусловно, рад. І це прекрасно.
Ми прощаємося з тобою, Юрий.
Юрий, ми з тобою прощаємося.
А ви вже попрощались, це скільки угодно, і не можете це нормально зробити.
І вот ждете в цього моменту, поки, не знаю, підтримка нажмет завершити, а він не завершається.
Подтримка вже не завершить, тому що вже права організації у мене.
Я завершаю цю конференцію. Іскренне рада ще раз.
Так, розкажіть, що таке аморфати для вас? Ви так мене не розказали.
Я вам в личку написала.
Ні, ви не сказали, ви сказали, що я не готова відповідати на цей вопрос.
Ні, ні.
А це, разве, не відповідь?
Дякую, що це відповідь.
А дай я жду.
Надіюсь, він зозрів.
Хороший відповідь.